foreign
this meeting of the Senate Judiciary
Committee
will come to order
at the outset I'd like to offer my
condolences to the families of Nashville
Tennessee
and to our colleague Senator Blackburn
for yesterday's horrific shooting at the
Covenant School
we're 93 days into this calendar year so
far we have had 131 mass shootings in
the United States
Congress and the United and the Supreme
Court
have allowed this tragic situation to
become the new Norm in America are we
going to do something about it I
certainly hope we do
today secretary Marcus is making a
second appearance before this committee
you know we're just over two years on
the job
notably during the previous
administration the homeland security
secretary appeared before the committee
one time in four years
this regular annual oversight hearing is
very important as a major function of
the Senate Judiciary Committee an
important part of our role in government
secretary America's thanks for being
here
as I told you yesterday I think you have
one of the most difficult jobs in the
administration after reading your
26-page opening statement I want to
amend those remarks with the possible
exception of the Secretary of Defense I
think you have the most challenging job
in this Administration the Department of
Homeland Security is responsible for
safeguarding our nation
facing a broad range of challenges
it Bears noting what they include
responding to horrible and uniquely
American phenomena like mass shootings
and the tragedy in Nashville
responding to natural disasters like the
tornadoes that devastated Rolling Fork
Mississippi
combating terrorism and the rising tide
of domestic violent extremism
addressing the surge in cyber attacks
against our schools businesses and
critical infrastructure
overseeing our nation's borders
immigration system and Transportation
Security and that's just the beginning
while the Biden Administration has taken
important steps to confront these
challenges we have a job to do in
Congress we must remain Vigilant and do
our part to provide the tools and
resources to address these challenges
you're going to get a lot of questions
about the southern border I'm sure you
know that
but here's the real question
what is it that Congress needs to do
when it comes to immigration in this
country we can certainly find fault with
what you have done we've done it before
with previous administrations as well
but what are we willing to do
it's easy to be critical but every
member of Congress needs to look in the
mirror only Congress can actually fix
our broken immigration system
I've tried for many years to work on a
bipartisan immigration bill
but many have stood in the way and said
nothing
they don't want any part of a solution
I want to commend my ranking member
Lindsey Graham Lindsay it's been 10
years since the gang of eight got
together and produced a bill which
passed with a strong bipartisan vote on
the floor for comprehensive immigration
reform
unfortunately it didn't become an item
of business and the republican-led house
in 2013. and diet industry result
that's why your testimony before this
Commission
committee ready rather
it basically tells us we still have a
job to complete
sadly Republicans in the house seem to
approach the same thing today as they
did 10 years ago to do nothing to block
attempted reform and criticize anyone
who suggests a solution to the problem
one leading house Republican has called
for defunding defunding the Department
of Homeland Security unimaginable
Mr secretary you're going to receive a
lot of questions today and some from me
about Fentanyl
this is a serious deadly problem with
fentanyl flowing in the United States
from two major Mexican cartels it
requires quick thoughtful urgent action
but we have to be clear-eyed about what
we're doing
some are pushing the narrative that
Asylum Seekers are smuggling fentanyl
across the border but the facts
tell a different story
it is predominantly U.S citizens
entering legally at ports of Entry who
are bringing these dangerous drugs into
the United States
so it's hard to understand why some of
opposed funding for technology like
non-intrusive inspection systems to help
Customs and Border Protection officers
to detect Fentanyl and vehicles coming
through these ports of Entry
the reality is DHS is working
aggressively the department just started
a new coordinated surge campaign
Operation Blue Lotus which stopped more
than 900 pounds of fentanyl in its first
week
we'll have to ask you some questions
about that and explore where you're
headed with that program
I hope we can work together
I also want to note the obvious our
legal immigration system needs to be
changed especially at a time when our
country has a desperate need for workers
we have 11 million unfilled jobs in this
country I constantly hear from employers
across the board in my home state of
Illinois about the need for more workers
agricultural Workers Health Care workers
and more
some Governors are so desperate to avoid
increasing any immigration that they are
now turning to relaxing child labor laws
as a solution to their shortages this is
Mindless turning back the clock to the
times of Upton Sinclair's jungle is
wrong and it's unnecessary when there
are skilled immigrants ready and willing
to fill these jobs
I'm heartened I want to make special
note that Republican governors in
Indiana and Utah recognizing this dire
need have written publicly in support of
more immigrant workers I hope their
voices are listened to
whether we're discussing our Southern
border the need for workers the
conclusion is the same
Congress needs to hold you accountable
yes but we've also got to stop pointing
fingers and act ourselves we should
start working together on a bipartisan
basis to fix our immigration system
today
and finally you won't be surprised that
I want to say a word about the dreamers
the dreamers after
the legislation that has been pending
for more than 20 years are still looking
for their path legal path to citizenship
our communities are desperate for these
new immigrant workers and DHS needs the
resources to secure our border all of us
on this committee have a choice we can
blame the secretary for a broken system
that we share with irresponsibility to
fix or we can come together on a
bipartisan basis to do our job with that
I'll turn to ranking member Graham for
his opening statement
well thank you Mr chairman I'm glad to
have you back uh you look like you
filled up well so
um
uh to the Heartbreak in Tennessee
uh it's unimaginable from
a parent's point of view was being
experienced in Tennessee there's so much
heartbreak in this world
uh the Heartbreak of fentanyl poisoning
you asked a rhetorical question of what
are we going to do about the shootings
in Tennessee
we passed some bipartisan proposals that
hopefully will help down the road
question back to you what are we going
to do about the poisoning of America
so here's what I would say America is
under attack
our nation is being attacked by foreign
powers called drug cartels in Mexico
when the Japanese attacked America and
Pearl Harbor they killed about 3 000
Americans 9 11 when we were attacked
about three thousand this is the largest
attack on American's Homeland by foreign
power in the history of the nation
seventy thousand Americans were poisoned
by fentanyl last year more than car
wrecks and
gun violence combined and it's getting
worse a couple of days ago Senator
Schumer had a news conference in New
York talking about the danger of mixing
fentanyl with a drug called xylazine he
called it sin uh skin rotting zombie
drug he called for the DEA to send teams
into New York to try to do something
about it he called for more education
when it comes to people using drugs I
would support both of those but what I'd
like to do is go to the source of the
problem what would America do if a
foreign power lobbed a rocket into let's
say our friends in Arizona or Texas we
would strike back
we're doing virtually nothing when it
comes to being under attack by drug
cartels that's deterring the behavior
Miss kaiserling who lost her children to
fentanyl said this is a war act like it
do something
our partner in Mexico basically is a
complete denial the president of Mexico
denies her safe havens for drug cartels
where they run parts of Mexico he says
that's not true he blames us for the
fentanyl crisis
he denies the fact that fentanyl is
produced in Mexico sent to America to
kill Americans so we got a real problem
Mr chairman and you asked what can
Congress do we'll keep working together
I'd like to work with him maybe we can
find a way to make some progress but
this idea that the executive branches
help us without Congress is ridiculous
you want to fix this Mr secretary go
back to Trump policies just reimpose
everything Donald Trump did to secure a
border and your problem will direct
dramatically be improved you're not
helpless
you change policies in a bad way and
you're getting a bad result we're under
attack by drug cartels
we've lost operational control of the
Border this secretary have said numerous
times we have control over the Border
the head of the border patrol about a
couple of weeks ago said we don't have
operational control of the Border well
anybody believes that we're in control
of the border is in denial we've lost
control of our border the number of
people coming across our border on the
Terrace watch list is going up like a
rocket
so what's my concern
General Corelli said the head of centcom
due to our withdrawal from Afghanistan
the likelihood of an attack coming
against America from Afghanistan uh
could mature within six months without
warning
you have a completely broken border you
have terrorism on the rise this is a
lethal combination but this is just not
me saying things we actually have some
evidence to suggest that what I'm saying
is factually true
in 2020 December we had the lowest
illegal Crossings in the last 40 years
because of trump policies
since those policies were changed
we've had 4.8 million
illegal encounters on the southern
border FY 21 1.7 million FY 22 2.4
million setting a record the first time
in the history of the country two men
illegal encounters at our border since
October of 2022 385
000 gotaways the lowest illegal
Crossings in the history of the country
for the last 40 years in December since
you and the Bible Administration been in
charge look what's happened
and you know how it happened you took
all the policies Mr secretary that
working and you changed them and it's
blown up in our faith
now fentanyl
Fentanyl
is killing Americans at levels we've
never seen
more people died last year from fentanyl
poisoning in a single year then the
entire Vietnam war that went on for over
a decade fentanyl poisoning is the
leading cause of death for 18 to 45 year
olds in the country
look what's happened in 2021 71
238 deaths from fentanyl poisoning
overdoses in 2023 year to day we see 11
000 pounds of fentanyl at the border the
year before fourteen thousand seven
hundred in 2014 none in 2015 70 pounds
11 000 pounds of fentanyl is enough to
kill 2.5 billion people how's this
happening where is it coming from it's
coming from Mexico
and China so when the Mexican president
denies that drug cartels are not in
charge of parts of Mexico he's either
lying or he has no idea what's going on
in his own country this is a state
department map
if you're looking to travel to Mexico
all these red zones do not travel
that's like going to Afghanistan or
Syria who controls these red zones drug
cartels that are making billions of
dollars off bringing fentanyl in the
country and human trafficking due to a
broken immigration system and quite
frankly we need to take the gloves off
they're at war with us we need to be at
war with them
now when it comes to uh
terrorists
people apprehended on the terrorist
watch list
2021 it was 15 2022 it's 98. to date
already 69. this is a lethal combination
people traveling to America on a
terrorist watch list the terrorists are
getting stronger because of our
withdrawal from Afghanistan and they're
coming here in larger numbers if we do
not change course if we do not change
where we're at
Americans are going to continue to die
from drug cartel poisoning
the illegal immigration problem is
exploding and the human misery around it
with no end in sight we went from the
lowest illegal Crossings in December
2020 to over 4.2 million on your watch
bottom line the Corelli
statement if we have it
It Is by command uh it is my Commander's
estimate that Isis K can do an external
operation against the U.S or Western
interest abroad in under six months well
little to no warning your own notice
your own notice you your department and
the president United States is on notice
one of our field commanders in charge of
the region right with terrorism is
telling this nation an open sworn
testimony that within six months the
enemy that's arising in Afghanistan has
the ability to attack this country
without warning
as he makes that statement
the lack of operational control of the
Border
is a lethal combination for this country
so Mr secretary
you have a hard job
I think things would change
if they would listen to you more
the bottom line is we've created a
nightmare for America and that nightmare
needs to end control our border go back
to Trump policies have the Congress work
together to fix immigration and are more
forward-looking fashion regain control
of the Border go after the cartels tell
the Mexican president get with it
work with us or we're going to have to
do things differently
secure the border now before we get
attacked later
thank you thank you Senator Graham today
we welcome the Secretary of Homeland
Security The Honorable Ali mayorkus to
testify before this committee let me lay
out the mechanics after I swear in the
secretary he will have five minutes to
provide an opening statement there will
be one round of questions each Senator
will have 10 minutes which is twice as
long as we normally allocate for
questions in recognition of the
importance of this hearing please remain
within your allotted time Secretary
Marcus will you please stand to be sworn
in
you affirm the testimony you're about to
get before the committee will be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth shall be God
let the record reflect that the
secretary answered in the affirmative
and with that please proceed to your
opening statement
thank you chairman Durbin ranking member
microphone
chairman Durbin
ranking member Graham and distinguished
members of this committee
on Sunday I traveled to Rolling Fork
Mississippi to assure the residents
there and others in Mississippi
devastated by the tornadoes that had
just struck that our department will
support their recovery in the days weeks
and months ahead
more than 20 people lost their lives and
many more lost their homes and all they
possessed
yesterday
I spoke with Senators Blackburn and
Hagerty and with Governor Lee and mayor
Cooper and offered our department
support in response to the tragic the
two tragic and senseless murder of
children and adults in Saint Paul
Christian school in Nashville Tennessee
Senator Blackburn I know this is very
personal to you and your connection to
the school and of course the community
our thoughts prayers and support are
with all who are suffering today
the threat landscape has evolved
significantly since our department was
created 20 years ago Homeland Security
as we thought of it in the wake of the 9
11 attacks today has new meaning
cyber attacks by criminals and adverse
Nations the rise of aggression by the
People's Republic of China
increasing in economic and political
instability around the world the rise of
domestic violent extremism the gravity
and frequency of extreme weather events
and other forces combine to create a
heightened threat environment here at
home
in addition the displacement of people
across the region is greater than at any
time since World War II to meet this
challenge the department is surging
resources hiring 300 additional border
patrol agents the first increase since
2011. investing in new technology
working with our partners in Mexico and
Central and South America and developing
Innovative processes to reduce irregular
migration at our Southwest border
over the past several months we have
implemented new measures for Cubans
Haitians nicaraguans and Venezuelans
that combine a lawful pathway for
eligible individuals with consequences
for those who cross the border without
authorization we have seen a decline of
about 95 percent in Encounters of
Nationals from these four countries
between our ports of Entry
we are attacking the cartels and
Smugglers like never before last year we
launched an unprecedented campaign that
has led to the arrest of more than 9 100
Smugglers and the disruption of over 9
000 human smuggling operations
through advanced screening and
enforcement surges like Operation Blue
Lotus that we announced last week we are
seizing record amounts of fentanyl at
our ports of Entry
the threat of terrorism has evolved to
include lone offenders who fueled by
hate anti-government ideologies false
narratives and personal grievances seek
to advance their political or social
goals through violence combating this
threat Demands a collaborative
community-centered approach
through our Center for prevention
programs and Partnerships and our grant
programs we help governments non-profit
organizations schools and houses of
worship build local prevention
capabilities and make physical security
improvements
we are transforming the way we
collaborate to stay ahead of cyber
threats posed by hostile Nations like
the PRC that seek to gain access to our
intellectual property data and
infrastructure after Russia's unprovoked
invasion of Ukraine our Shields up
initiative galvanized tens of thousands
of businesses to implement urgent cyber
security improvements
through groundbreaking public-private
initiatives like the joint cyber defense
collaborative the Cyber safety review
board and our cyber security performance
goals we are hardening the Cyber
defenses of businesses critical
infrastructure and the public and we are
deepening our International Security
Partnerships including by expanding the
Abraham Accords to Encompass shared
cyber security goals
emerging emerging technology is creating
new threats unmanned aircraft systems
can be used to conduct attacks and
increasingly violate temporary flight
restrictions that protect high-ranking
officials disrupt airport operations
surveil outdoor Mass Gatherings and
attempt to transport illegal narcotics
across borders it is vital that Congress
act to extend extend and expand the the
Department's counter uas authorities to
protect against malicious drone activity
separately it is critical that Congress
fully renew section 702 of the foreign
intelligence surveillance act which
provides fast reliable and specific
insights that enhance our understanding
of the threats posed by our adversaries
every day
every day the 260 000 dedicated public
servants of the Department of Homeland
Security work tirelessly to deliver
Safety and Security to the American
people
our mission has never been more vital
our components have never collaborated
more closely and our nation has never
been more prepared
we know that we have a great deal of
work still ahead of us the nonpartisan
Spirit of collaboration upon which our
department was founded is needed now
more than ever to address the challenges
we face
thank you very much I look forward to
your questions thanks Mr secretary let
me start my questioning where Senator
Graham left off
we have a bipartisan concern about
fentanyl in the United States as a
secretary or pardon me Senator Graham
mentioned seventy thousand fatal
overdoses in the U.S every year
we need to launch the President says we
need to launch a major surge to stop
fentanyl production and sale
I'd like to start at the obvious place
where is it coming from well it may
start with precursor chemicals in China
but it certainly comes through the two
major drug cartels in Mexico which are
the major exporters into the United
States Jalisco and Sinaloa here's what
the former Mexican ambassador to the
United States Arturo sir Khan said
Mr Sarah Khan said only a handful of law
enforcement agencies in Mexico are
willing or able to engage with the
powerful drug gangs quote there's no
doubt that endemic corruption impunity a
weak rule of law or Mexico's Achilles
heels he went on to say that means
Fentanyl and methamphetamine Labs
operate in Mexico with almost no
pressure
I've had two lengthy conversations with
Anne Milgram with the drug enforcement
agency
Administration about this challenge of
fentanyl I will say I want to mention to
my colleague Senator Graham and others
on the committee when we get into the
world of social media in a couple weeks
in this committee one of the first stops
will be Snapchat for me because
according to DEA this is the major
Clearinghouse for the sale of fentanyl
in the United States these fake drugs
that they're being sold so my question
to you is
not easily answered and maybe impossible
to answer tell me how we strike a
relationship with Mexico to actively
cooperate in the flow of individuals who
are coming toward the United States
while at the same time deal with the
reality that they are failing miserably
when it comes to the export of deadly
narcotics to our country
Mr chairman you and ranking member
Graham accurately described the cartels
as vicious ruthless organizations that
peddle in the death of individuals
including tens of thousands of Americans
we in the Department of Homeland
Security are taking it to the cartels
and the smuggling organizations with
which they work in unprecedented fashion
and you noted as did I Operation Blue
Lotus the most recent surge of personnel
and other resources and intelligence to
take it to those cartels we're seizing
more fentanyl at our ports of Entry than
ever before we in the Department of
Homeland Security through Homeland
Security investigations the criminal
investigative arm of Immigration and
Customs Enforcement are working with our
Mexican counterparts on an increasing
level we have transnational criminal
investigative units that have indeed
disrupted Laboratories that manufacture
fentanyl that have helped interdict the
flow of fentanyl within Mexico that have
in fact cut off Financial streams but
the battle is very difficult and we are
seeking to cooperate more closely with
our Mexican counterpart our and we're
doing so in an all of administration
effort not just the Department of
Homeland Security not just the
Department of Justice of which the DEA
is a part but across the entire
Administration so let me ask you about
the effort we're making a lot of
publicity has come out with the notion
that people seeking Asylum or Refugee
status are really transporting fentanyl
into the United States the chart which I
demonstrated earlier suggests that 80 or
more is actually coming from American
citizens Crossing in ports of Entry if
we eliminated every applicant for Asylum
or Refugee status we would still have a
tremendous flow of deadly narcotics
coming in across the border is it in
possible for us in this day and age to
stop this Flow by ordinary legal
Americans through our ports of Entry of
Narcotics
Mr chairman we are working intensely uh
to devote additional resources to the
ports of Entry at the on the land of our
Southern border that is where more than
90 percent of the fentanyl is
transported through passenger vehicles
through trucks uh by pedestrians that
are lawfully coming into the United
States through the ports of Entry we are
surging resources to the ports of Entry
to battle that we are seeking more
resources in our fiscal year 2024 budget
for precisely that purpose to add
Personnel to add non-intrusive
inspection technology to allow our
forward operating labs to detect the
substance at the point of interdiction
so we can bring our investigative and
prosecutive capabilities right there and
develop the force that we need to
to put some perspective on this it's my
understanding that a backpack full of
fentanyl is dangerous to thousands of
people if it makes it into the United
States and we are talking about
transport trucks flowing across our
border by the thousands every single day
is does there exist technology to detect
this fentanyl in these carriers coming
into the United States there is uh Mr
chairman it is called non-intrusive
inspection technology we are investing
more in that uh in addition we are
exploring how we can use artificial
intelligence to really serve as a force
multiplier of our incredible border
patrol agents and our incredible office
of field operations officers who do such
heroic work uh in this regard so we put
some more money on the table for you
when it comes to this technology how
much more do you need we are seeking
more than um we're seeking hundreds of
millions of dollars for non-intrusive
inspection technology in our fiscal year
2024 budget we are also seeking to plus
up our Personnel both our officers in
office of field operations and our
border patrol agents well I certainly
hope we have bipartisan support for that
when it comes before the Senate and the
House of Representatives there was one
aspect of your opening statement which
you noted uh in summary before us that
caught my eye and that was the issue of
drones would you please explain why that
has become a new and concerning threat
to you
Mr chairman the technology has advanced
so significantly in the area of drones
as it has in so many different areas
these drones can fly farther uh faster
have greater visibility carry heavier
loads and they are being used by
individuals with nefarious intent as
well as by an adverse nation states and
we need to have the capability to
counter the use of drones they invade
our airspace they hover over public
Gatherings with bad intent we have got
to be able to counter them we have the
authority now it's sunsets we need to
renew it and also Mr chairman we need to
expand it
well I'm certainly open to that as I
think many of my colleagues are so let's
work on that issue as well I was briefed
two or three weeks ago on artificial
intelligence it was a frightening uh
presentation when you consider the
opportunities of AI to overcome what we
think are our Protections in cyber
security you mentioned artificial
intelligence in your opening statement
can you comment on the challenge it's
going to create for us Mr chairman I um
I am tasking the homeland security
advisory Council to provide advice to us
in this regard we of course are already
focused on it but want a different
perspectives artificial intelligence
presents an opportunity an opportunity
for good that we seek to harness to
really serve as a force multiplier in
advancing the security of our country at
the same time in the wrong hands it can
be a weapon it could be a weapon of harm
and we have to build the defenses that
are ready to secure the Homeland with
respect to the potential that AI
presents last point I'll make to use it
I have been meeting as I told you in our
phone conversation yesterday with many
of the immigrants who've come to the
city of Chicago and sat down with them
in conversation as to their backgrounds
and why they came here
I will tell you without exception not a
single one of them asked for the address
of the local welfare office
virtually every one of them asked me
where can I go to work now we have this
system of law that
does not allow a person to legally work
in the United States until a period of
time has passed six months to a year
once they're in here even waiting for a
determination of their Refugee status
that creates a dilemma for many of these
people who have no resources to live on
how do you answer critics who say we
ought to give them an opportunity to
work
Mr chairman the law provides that an
individual can seek work authorization
after their application for Asylum has
been pending for 150 days
and of course that can be lengthened
unfortunately to longer periods of time
as they're waiting for that
determination isn't that true yes yes
that is that is true and um We Are
Climbing uh out of a out of a backlog
because U.S citizenship and Immigration
Services the agency that it issues the
work authorizations was financially
devastated in the prior Administration
um uh it is funded primarily through
fees uh every two years it is to issue a
new fee rule that calibrates the cost of
immigration benefits uh according to the
cost of operationalizing their
Administration a fee rule has not been
issued for more than six years and we
have a pending proposed Rule now to
really readjust realign the costs of
immigration benefits to the cost of the
agency to administer them thank you Mr
secretary Senator Graham
thank you uh
the Mexican president Mr oberdorf said
he denied that there were parts of his
country
uh under control of cartels do you agree
with him
I do not um you agree with secretary
blanken that there are parts of Mexico
run by drug cartels I do okay do you
consider Mexico a reliable partner in
this fight regarding Fentanyl and legal
immigration uh ranking member Graham we
we are working with Mexico uh on the
fight against uh fentanyl are they a
reliable partner we have brought great
cases uh together and we are looking to
enhance our cooperation so if we do the
things I'm going to work with Senator
Durbin to give you more money
at the border to interdict and let's see
how that works I hope it works
do you think you have a plan in place
that will severely reduce the fentanyl
problem in America
ranking member Graham I think there are
two primary elements to the fight
against fennel one is the supply which
we are very very focused on and I want
to touch upon that uh in a moment uh and
the second of course is the issue of
demand uh and we need to address both
elements of that
um we we need to we need to also
interrupt but a lot of these poisonings
or people are buying what they think to
be percocet or perkadan and it's got
fentanyl over it absolutely they're not
demanding fentanyl they're getting
fentanyl laced drugs that are uh phony
drugs ranking member Graham
um absolutely and I have heard you speak
uh about the fact that we need severe
penalties for the individuals who
traffic in Fentanyl and I agree with you
okay and uh if I if I may yes
um in addition
to um increasing
our work with Mexico
we also have to address the fact that
precursor chemicals as well as the
equipment used to manufacture synthetic
dangerous fatal narcotics are
originating from China okay less that's
a good point right now drug cartel
cartels are labeled as transnational
criminal organizations are you aware of
that
a foreign terrorist organization
designation would mean any group country
that supplies material support to an fto
would be subject to American
jurisdiction do you support
labeling these drug cartels as ftos
under U.S law ranking member Graham I I
have heard you speak of this issue as
well I share your view of 100 that these
are ruthless vicious petals what do you
support my efforts to make them ft this
this is a decision that rests in the in
the jurisdiction of the Department of
State and it is a difficult question as
to where the line between nominality
however vicious and terrorism is strong
and I'd be happy when you kill seventy
thousand Americans you have crossed the
line but you know that's not your Bailey
let's go to to your area uh you said uh
on April
2022 in a house hearing
uh you're asked directly do we have
operational control of Southern border
right now yes or no you said yes we do
later in that hearing it said the Border
was in fact not open about a week or two
ago March 15th the border patrol Chief
Mr Ortiz I think said when asked does
dhf DHS has operational control of our
entire border uh he said no sir
do we or don't we I'd like to be able to
answer that question fully
just a ranking ranking member take your
time but not too long because I don't
have much time let me be clear number
one we are intensely focused on securing
the Border number two we are equally
focused on enforcing our laws to achieve
that result number three the border
patrol agents and all the Personnel the
Department of Homeland Security are
doing heroic work in that regard with
respect to the definition of operational
control I do not use the definition that
appears in the secure fence Act and the
security fence act provides
statutorily that operational control is
defined as preventing all unlawful
injuries into the United States by that
definition no Administration has ever
had operational control it's the way I
Define it is maximizing the resources
that we have to deliver the most
effective results and we are indeed
doing that we have for the first time
since 2000 11 increased the number of
border patrol agents
is everything you do in working is any
of it working to stop the poisoning of
America or the reduction in a meaningful
way of the historic illegal immigration
problem right now today do you believe
you have a plan that's working
right ranking member Graham I must
separate the number of individuals
arriving at a border who are claiming
relief from the issue of fentanyl that
is coming through our ports of Entry
that is too often conflated I agree you
are fundamentally fundamentally we are
working within a system that is
absolutely broken and there is unanimity
whose problem is that
who who broke this system that you're
trying to fix
um was it Trump is it Trump's problem
ranking member Graham this is our
Collective problem you've been and we
need to collectively now you've been DHS
secretary and I honestly God do like you
I think you're a very good man on your
watch Mr secretary we've gone from the
lowest illegal Crossings in December
2020 to all-time highs with over 2
million last fiscal year on your watch
fentanyl is coming in at a pace we've
never seen more Americans are dying on
your watch more terrorists are coming
into the country on the watch list than
any time we've been measuring these
things so I'm trying to get some
appreciation from you that things are
not going well your own border patrol
Chief said we don't have operational
control of the border and I don't think
it's a definitional problem I think he's
just been really honest with it with us
so I would like to work with you where I
can you need more money for interdiction
I will work with Senator durman to get
it to you but we play around with the
problems we don't address them mayor
Adams went to the border from New York
he's not exactly a right-wing guy he
said this is a national crisis and he
said basically it's a disaster everybody
that goes has a different view Democrats
and Republicans so what I would like to
just get from you is some recognition of
where we're at and I don't think where
we're going it's where is going to get
us to the promised land you know I asked
you back in the last time we were here
to give yourself a grade you gave
yourself an a for effort how would you
grade yourself for outcome since we last
met ranking member Graham I
certainly appreciate and understand the
gravity of the challenge that we are
facing it is a very serious challenge I
look forward to working with you with
respect to the funding for this
department as well as the hope that we
can work together right to fix the
immigration I've got an idea for you on
just to entertainment my time's about up
uh
the Cradle the credible fear standard is
the screening standard when somebody
applies for Asylum is that correct yes
it is okay what's the final adjudication
standard
um ranking member Graham the credible
fear standard is the initial threshold
and it is set by Statute
as a substantial likelihood of fear of
persecution so here's my offer what's
the final significance forgive me a
significant uh a possibility okay
persecution okay here's the final
adjudication standard reasonable
possibility of suffering persecution on
account of race religion nationality
membership in a particular social group
or political opinion that's the final
adjudication standard what percentage of
people who pass the initial screening
standard are given Asylum
using the second standard ranking member
Graham if I understand your question
correctly what is the let's say average
because it changes by if you have 100
passing the the screening test of
critical uh fear how many of them are
granted Asylum through the adjudication
process percentage-wise it varies
according to country of origin I can
tell you is is is averaging ten percent
um
so ninety percent of the people that
pass their credible fear standard never
make it here's a proposal why don't we
make the adjudication standard the
initial screening standard I'm willing
to change the law with my Democratic
friends one or two things is happening
you're denying 90 of people with a
legitimate claim which I don't believe
or when you look at their claim it's not
it's an economic problem it doesn't meet
the stature or definition if you want to
stop Asylum seeking change the standard
because once they get here they never
leave so I'm willing to work with you
are you willing to a final question
would you entertain changing the
credible fear standard
as a screening standard to
the final adjudication standard ranking
member Graham I would welcome the
opportunity to work with you to perform
great clearly a broken immigration thank
you that's a good place to start thanks
Senator Graham Senator Whitehouse
thanks very much welcome secretary and
thank you chairman for this hearing
um as the chair of the Senate caucus on
International narcotics control I've
been working to focus more
on the financial networks and flows that
support the international drug
cartels
um my experience in my U.S attorney days
and in many years on this committee has
been that we put a great deal of focus
on the importation
of drugs from these cartels and by these
cartels
but for every package that comes over
the Border there are dollars that flow
back to the cartels and I think we've
been less successful at degrading
exposing and ultimately destroying the
financial networks upon which these
cartels rely what in your view are the
things that you could be doing to more
effectively attack the financial side of
the drug cartel Network
Senator Whitehouse um uh I I share
your experience as a former United
States Attorney as a matter of fact I
was a federal prosecutor for 12 years
almost nine years as an assistant we've
all done the press conferences with the
drugs and the guns and the cash
um so we are already
seeking to disrupt the financial
networks of the cartels in an
unprecedented way within the Department
of Homeland Security our homeland
security investigations agents are very
focused on that and they are attacking
that not alone but by with their
Partners in the federal government are
we like a proper briefing on that would
you coordinate that for me and invite
other members of the committee to join
if they would like most certainly uh
Senator because I would also like other
partners of ours to join in that
briefing from the Department of Justice
as well as from the treasury Department
it strikes me that there are
um American interests that can
facilitate
these Financial transactions
whether it's through law firms or hedge
funds or yacht Brokers or whatever
um it is part of a general Global
problem of kleptocrat secret financing
kleptocurred and criminal secret
financing and I look forward to working
with you to improve what we're doing
against that and in particular to build
support for the law the enablers act
that would in the same way that we
prevent Banks from going about this
business and we've begun to investigate
shell corporations who go out about this
business we'll be able to put some
restraints on American law firms yacht
Brokers Realtors hedge fund managers and
others who facilitate this trade so look
forward to working with you on that
separate matter you oversee the Coast
Guard
um there is a very significant
pirate fishing problem which also
overlays with a slave ship problem which
also overlays with a vector for drugs
and weapons and other
evils problem
the Coast Guard has a very important
role in all of this
recently in Panama secretary Del Toro of
the Navy and your Deputy commandant
Peter Gautier met to discuss improving
the engagement of the Coast Guard and
the Navy together
I would like to ask you to get back to
me in writing
this is a question for the record first
what are the next steps you need
including steps by secretary Del Toro to
make sure that the Navy is fully
supporting the Coast Guard's effort
against the international pirate fishing
fleet and against the Chinese fishing
fleet where it's violating International
and local laws question one
question two what additional resources
does the Coast Guard need
to do that International work I will
tell you that when Lindsay and I
that led the previous Munich security
conference delegation General Townsend
was then in charge of africom and he and
his briefing
told us not in response to questions he
volunteered that one of the things
that's important to the success of the
Africa mission is the ability to get
after the pirate fishing and Chinese
fishing fleets that are operating in the
eez waters of these African allies
without their even knowing it because
they don't have the capacity to do it
and if he believes it will help our
national security mission on that
continent if we can more aggressively
track
and identify and alert the local
authorities to the presence of pirate
fishing so
the Coast Guard does not have the global
footprint that the Navy does what do you
need that's question two last question
is that
um for lack of official
enforcement by the United States
government
the NGO Community has stepped up in
important ways to do enforcement whether
it's Global fishing watch or Vulcan or
Sea Shepherd there's a whole array of
ngos who operate in this space
they both need intelligence
about the location
of these pirate vessels
and they can offer intelligence it can
be a two-way street they're very active
and they're quite capable
we are trying to figure out
how we can set it up so that they can
have access to appropriate intelligence
that can be deployed in real time
against Real vessels when they cross
real boundaries
um and do so in a way that protects the
sources and methods and the
classified
matters that we should not be allowing
to get out I think there's the ability
to create sort of a vestibule where the
information that's needed can go in be
screened and then once it's screened get
out but be screened like in real time
not one of these you know whole of
government
interagency task force things where it
takes a decade
uh I would like to ask your commitment
to help set that up so that we can be
both receiving and providing
intelligence about these uh vessels in
real time you have my commitment uh
senator may I say to uh brief things go
for it one uh is the U.S Coast Guard is
doing uh extraordinary work in this area
uh I have been briefed a number of times
with respect to what it has been doing
in South America specifically you
identify uh illegal fishing and and
specifically the aggressive actions of
the PRC in this regard it is very much a
a problem by the way do you agree that
the fleet
that the PRC has launched also often
accomplishes other goals for the
communist government in China involving
surveillance and
um
non-fishing activities that is certainly
a very significant concern of ours with
respect to uh the dissemination of
intelligence and information one of the
overarching objectives of our Office of
Intelligence and Analysis is to
distribute as widely as possible as much
Intel and information as possible in
real time that is relevant and
actionable at the lowest classification
level possible so your request to get
this information out to the force
multipliers in Civil Society is
something that I will take back to our
understanding you actually have good
models for doing this in other areas yes
to be applied readily in the IU fishing
area so I look forward to working with
you on that and to your written reply to
those three questions which I'm sure
your diligent staff were carefully
writing down behind you the last thing
uniting for Ukraine
I think we've been able to give shelter
to 50 000 ukrainians fleeing Putin's
atrocities and brutalities in Ukraine
more than that Senator is there anything
more that you need to help the U.S
help more payroll leads from Ukraine
find temporary shelter here until
Ukraine can achieve its Victory so we we
are very focused on uniting for Ukraine
I believe the last figure I saw was that
we have provided a relief for more than
a hundred thousand uh ukrainians I will
confirm that figure one of the um one of
the needs that we have is to Resource
U.S citizenship and Immigration Services
as I referenced earlier it was an agency
that was financially devastated during
the prior Administration and we're very
focused on getting it back into a safe
and secure Financial condition
it seems uh clear to me that Ukraine has
demonstrated enormous patriotism
and that those who have fled the
brutalities and atrocities of Vladimir
Putin uh are truly seeking only
temporary shelter and employment here so
that they they can go back and help
rebuild their lives and their country is
that your experience as well yes it is
Senator thank you very much thank you
chairman
Senator White House Senator Grassley
thank you thank you for coming Mr
secretary there are several reports of
foreign Nations like China purchasing of
U.S land for farming or agricultural
purposes some of these tracks of the
land are suspiciously close to American
military bases or critical
infrastructure sites uh the committee on
foreign investment in the United States
expressed great concern in a North
Dakota purchase of Farmland by China is
one example of their concern how is
Homeland Security working with the
Department of Agriculture and law
enforcement entities to track these
types of suspicious land purchases
Senator Grassley we are very focused on
the threat that the People's Republic of
China poses to the United States in a
number of regards you have cited one of
them
and we are a member of cypheus the
committee for foreign investment in the
U.S we are one of the department events
that reviews a potential transactions to
assess the threat that a transaction
poses not only in isolated uh context
but in the aggregate of the threat it
poses to the security of the United
States and we seek to impose measures on
the transaction to mitigate any threat
successfully and if that threat cannot
be adequately mitigated through the
measures that we take then it would be
our recommendation to prevent the
transaction from occurring uh do you uh
as a follow-up do you have a way of
notifying relevant parties that maybe
targets the possible Espeon odds from
these uh purchases
um there is a very established process
that the committee for foreign
investment in the United States sypheus
follows with respect to the transactions
and the committee's engagement with the
parties to the transaction
over two years ago on February the 11th
uh
21 I wrote to you and asked these
questions and I'll repeat these
questions later on
the first question was whether the
department Homeland Security considers
Confucius institutes and their
Affiliates to be an extension of
communist Chinese government and two if
the department believed them to be
purveyors of communist Chinese
government propaganda I would hope the
answers to those questions would be
obvious to anybody in the Biden
Administration we all know that the
National Security threats that Confucius
institutes posed and we can draw that
conclusion based upon what the Chinese
government's own words say about these
institutions and many educational
institutions have already shut down
their Confucius institutes And yet when
you answered my February letter July
29th of 21 you personally responded and
failed to answer the critical questions
so I'm going to pose these questions to
you again whether the department
Homeland Security considers Confucius
institutes and their Affiliates to be an
extension of the Communist Chinese
government and if the department
believes them to be purveyors of
communist Chinese propaganda uh Senator
we are we are very concerned about the
institutes that you mentioned uh in fact
we are very concerned about the prc's
use of what we call non-traditional
collectors of intelligence it is why we
are working with the Department of State
to ensure that our Visa system is secure
as against that threat
well for any college University or other
educational institution in the United
States that maintains such an Institute
connector with China would you advise
those educational institutions to close
them based on national security reasons
if not why not uh Senator we work as do
others in the United States government
work with institutions of Higher
Learning to inform them of the threat
that the PRC opposes and to deliver
recommended safeguards to guard against
that threat okay let me go back to one
of those first two questions I ask you
just to get clarification do you believe
these institutes to be purveyors of
communist Chinese government propaganda
I am very concerned that many of them
are indeed Senator and we we seek to
guard against the realization of that
threat
uh
then going back to something I was going
to ask you a whole series of questions
that Senator Graham already answered but
one that I want to follow up on
uh is for the committee's record would
you describe which foreign drug cartels
control areas of the Southern border and
the areas they control the the two
um cartels Senator that are of greatest
concern to us are the Sinaloa cartel and
the Jalisco New Generation cartel as the
primary
traffickers of synthetic opioids
including the deadly Fentanyl
okay
uh multiple inspectors General have
found that Department of Homeland
Security failed to fully vet and Screen
Afghan evacu evacuees before entering
the United States in one report the
defense department Inspector General
said that 50 evacuees in the United
States pose potential significant
National Security concerns how many
Afghan evacuees are currently in the
country who pose potential or actual
National Security concerns uh Senator I
um I respectfully
disagree with certain aspects of the
Inspector General reports that you
referenced and I would be pleased to
provide you and your staff with a
briefing with respect to the security
screening and vetting that we performed
with respect to the Afghan Nationals who
are seeking a relief in the United
States and the disposition of those
individuals
I respectfully disagree with you that
this is classified and you can't answer
it in this setting but I'll go on to
another question does the Department of
Homeland Security know the location of
these Afghan evacuees in the United
States who pose a potential national
security threat and if you don't know
where they are why you don't know where
they are Senator if an individual
opposes a national security threat that
individual is either removed from the
United States or detained
so if there are if there are other
reasons for either of those dispositions
to not occur uh then that is something
that I can share with you in an
appropriate briefing did you did you
just tell me in your answer that there's
none of these evacuees that are serious
threat to the United States no
um Senator what I would like to make
clear if I if I wasn't clear initially
is that we screen in vet uh individuals
before they uh arrive if an individual
does arrive and we determine that the
individual presents either a public
safety or a national security threat we
will place that individual in removal
proceedings and seek to detain that
individual if that disposition is not
reached there may be considerations why
that is so and I would welcome the
opportunity uh to brief you on that more
specifically
well do you coordinate with the FBI's
ongoing assessment and investigation of
Afghan evacuees in the United States yes
we most certainly do
okay on January the 23rd this year
Senator Johnson I sent a letter
to the Secret Service
requesting visitor logs for President
Biden's residence our letter in part is
part of a review that we began in two
years ago
of President Biden's compliance with
Federal records laws dating back to the
time that he was vice vice president
our records our request was also based
on news reports that the Secret Service
was prepared to turn those records over
to Congress pursue it to a request since
then my and Senator Johnson staff have
been told that the your Department's
office of general counsel is the barrier
to the Secret Service producing relevant
material to Congress it appears that the
office of general counsel is being used
to shield and frustrate and obstruct
congressional oversight what steps have
you instructed the office of general
counsel to take to produce the requested
material to me and Senator Johnson and
what legal barriers exist to producing
these Secret Service visitors logs to
Congress if they can't be given to
Congress senator two things number one
uh the directive that I have issued is
for our department to cooperate uh and
comply with our oversight
responsibilities and the requests that
are made of us and two it is certainly
false that the office of general counsel
serves as a barrier to that cooperation
and compliance sounds to me like we'll
get those records in is that right I
don't know um uh whether the Secret
Service maintains visitor logs of the
president's residence but if they do and
those have been requested we will comply
with the law okay thank you thanks
Senator Grassley Senator Blumenthal
Mr chairman thanks Mr secretary for your
service and thank you for being here
today I want to begin
with an issue involving International
students
in particular I'm rooting for UConn in
the final four
the men's team is powered by an
incredibly talented
and successful forward name Adamo
senago who is not a citizen
and unfortunately unlike his teammates
he cannot benefit from his name image
and likeness
although he is a star
the rules have been revised two years
ago the NCAA at the urging of myself and
others allowed student athletes to
benefit from their name image and
likeness
and uh
International students like him and
Aaliyah Edwards on our women's team
other athletes in other sports who are
international students are
prevented by student visa rules from
benefiting from Financial opportunities
and indeed their educational Futures
because of these rules I sent a letter
to you calling on DHS to issue guidance
and open rulemaking
to enable some fairness and Equity here
but the schools haven't received
guidance from DHS about student visas
and nio will you commit to publishing
guidance
or issuing rulemaking to ensure that
Adama and Alia and other International
students on the Huskies and other teams
have a fair opportunity on their nil
rights for their entire college career
Senator thank you for your letter on
this subject which brought the issue to
my attention I was not aware of it
previously we are indeed looking at the
issue very carefully and I hope quickly
and we will move with deliberate speed
yes
deliberate speed meaning practically
very soon
yes we'll move as quickly as we can
Senator thank you I want to talk a
little bit about Tick Tock and data
security
I don't need to emphasize to you the
concern that we have
not only about the
destructive effects of driving toxic
content to kids through the algorithms
of tick tock and other social media
but uh given DHS concern and focus on
cyber security and the threats of
foreign Espionage uh do you have
concerns about the safety of tick tock's
user data and the independence of tick
tock from the Chinese government Senator
I certainly do and I have a tremendous
concern with respect to many uh aspects
of the prc's aggression with respect to
the United States and other democracies
around the world without going into the
details in this setting
are those concerns based on evidence
that in fact there is Chinese
surveillance through Tick Tock
um a senator I would um I would refrain
from answering that question directly in
this setting and I should also note that
there are legal proceedings uh pending
with respect to uh Tick Tock and so I I
will respectfully refrain but let me be
clear that we're very concerned about
the um the security implications of tick
tock you're a member of the cypheus
panel which has a responsibility has an
ongoing proceeding which has been
lagging for
some years I think at this point can you
commit to that proceeding coming to a
conclusion
Senator there's a litigation uh pending
we are very focused on the the threat
that Tick Tock uh presents and you have
my Assurance that we are addressing that
with tremendous vigilance I'm not asking
for details in this setting but simply
not only the assurance that you will act
promptly but that it will be on the
basis of evidence that you have right
now I think that evidence is there of
the threat of Chinese surveillance am I
correct it the the disposition will be
based on the evidence that we have and
any additional evidence that we acquire
um recently I joined a number of my
colleagues in asking you about
the
proposals with regard to family
detention
can you update us as to what the
administration's policy is we expressed
our concerns about reports that that
policy might be adopted in the near
future
Senator no decision has been made we
ended family detention in March of 2021
no decision has been made and I seek to
encourage a work environment where
people can present uh their ideas
um many are left on The Cutting Room
floor uh others become policy others
spring new ideas that's the type of
environment that I seek to create
I take it from that answer that no
decision has been made no decision has
been made and the reports
about you're considering it don't imply
that it will be adopted as a problem
that is correct
uh
there have been various suggestions and
and I have joined in
the idea that maybe it are be considered
for
drug cartels to be regarded as foreign
terrorist organizations
is there serious consideration to that
idea being given Senator this is a a
matter in the province of the Department
of State it's a very complicated
question because it obviously has
Foreign Relations uh implications uh I
certainly agree uh with both the
chairman ranking member Graham with
respect to the perniciousness the
viciousness of the cartels and it is
precisely why we are attacking them with
the full force of our law enforcement
capabilities
can you tell me about Operation Blue
Lotus and what can be accomplished
through that Operation Blue Lotus
Senator is a surge operation that we
implemented
um to address the increased interdiction
of
fennel at the ports of Entry most of the
fentanyl more than 90 percent of the
fentanyl that enters the United States
is brought in through the ports of Entry
we surged resources including the
extraordinary Special Agents of Homeland
Security investigations to the ports of
Entry uh to enhance our interdiction
capabilities to enhance our
investigative capabilities and bring a
greater level of prosecutions to Bear we
had as the chairman noted tremendous
success within just the first week of
operation Blue Lotus I received the
latest update last night with respect to
some of the seizures of fentanyl that we
were able to accomplish as part of that
operation will it be expanded it is my
hope that we have additional funding to
expand it and we are certainly going to
continue with that operation
I was very pleased to see that the
department has recently announced that
it would give a one-year parole
an extension to an estimated 25 000
ukrainians and their immediate family
members
who have come here in the wake of the
murderous assault by the Russians crime
against humanity as the president's
correctly called it
this extension and my view is one step
as you know I've advocated for our
country to provide not only strong
military and humanitarian support to
Ukraine but also the assurance that
Ukrainian refugees coming here
will be safe and welcome in our country
uh what kind of support and resources
does DHS need to
further process and expand the number of
refugees who will be welcome here
Senator thank you very much
um the uniting for Ukraine a very
Innovative program that we implemented
is a tremendous source of Pride for us
and we are
tremendously committed to continuing it
U.S citizenship and Immigration Services
is under tremendous Financial strain and
we are seeking additional funding for
that agency in addition we have a notice
of proposed rulemaking to readjust its
cost schedule to make sure that the fees
that charged are calibrated according to
the cost incurred in administrating uh
the benefits provided so we're trying to
get that Agency on firm stable footing
because it was on the brink of
bankruptcy in the prior Administration
let me ask you likewise uh will you
support the Afghan adjustment act which
I have championed a number of us on this
committee have supported yes and we very
much appreciate your championing of it
thank you thanks Senator Bloom with all
senator cornyn Mr secretary when the
Attorney General of the United States
was here a couple of weeks ago I asked
him whether he was aware of the strategy
of transnational criminal organizations
to flood the border with migrants in a
manner to overwhelm the border patrol so
that then they could move drugs across
the border and he said he was aware of
that strategy
are you familiar with that strategy do
you agree with the attorney general I I
am not aware of that as a strategy I am
certainly aware of the significant
challenge if you're not aware of the
strategy
they move migrants and they move drugs
for money right yes they do the cartels
so what better what better way to
move drugs into the United States than
to overwhelm
the border patrol with migrants so and
divert their attention from their drug
interdiction responsibilities Senator
cornyn um
uh more than 90 percent of the fentanyl
or about 90 of the fentanyl that is
brought into these that's what's totally
made up number you had you had nearly a
million people get away from border
patrol evade border patrols detection
and detention uh between 2022 and 2023
you have no idea how many of those
people were carrying fentanyl or other
drugs with them do you uh Senator the um
uh the uh expert uh view that I received
is that approximately 90 percent of the
fentanyl that's a totally made up number
Mr secretary you know it that's a
totally made up number um Senator that
the expert information that I received
is that approximately 90 of the fentanyl
is brought in through the ports of Entry
through uh passenger vehicles through
trucks through pedestrians Mr secretary
you understand that you have a
credibility problem with the uh with the
Congress and with the American people
don't you I have unflinching confidence
in the Integrity of my conduct
no I'm saying you have told us two
patently inconsistent things
for example
you said we do have operational control
of the Border in 2022 you said the
border is not in fact open and then I
think I heard you say here that no
Administration has ever had operational
control of the Border
isn't that what you said I know
that is not what I said
that's not what you said well I will
reflect may I clarify 4.8 million people
coming to the border and being ushered
into the interior of the United States
perhaps never to be identified or heard
from again and with a hundred and eight
thousand Americans dying of drug
overdoses last year alone with those
drugs flooding across the border you
think everything is just hunky-dory that
is absolutely not true Senator no I
understand that I understand your answer
you said it's not true and I disagree
with you Senator last month I went to
Hayes Consolidated Independent School
District in Kyle Texas
and I met with Shannon and Darren
mcconville and Brandon Dunn and Janelle
Rodriguez
the mcconnels lost their 17 year old son
Kevin
to fentanyl poisoning
um
he had pizza for dinner and then came
back down looking for a second helping
and none was left his mom said so she
offered making the tuna fish sandwich
and instead he went upstairs and went to
bed and when they went to his bedroom
the next morning to wake him up he was
dead because of fentanyl poisoning
Brandon Dunn and Janelle Rodriguez 15
year old son Noah Who Loved Sports they
called him a genuine kind and a jokester
he began his his mental condition began
to deteriorate during covid-19 and
unfortunately it had some experience
with illicit drugs but
while spending the night at a friend's
house during the first weekend of the
school year Noah took a pill laced with
fentanyl and died of fentanyl poisoning
Mr secretary would you like to take the
opportunity here today to apologize to
these parents who lost their children
because of fentanyl poisoning because of
the policies of your department and the
Biden Administration
would you like to apologize to him
senator
my heart is with the family
of every victim of the drug overdose
death
is that an apology my heart is with the
family and the loved ones and the
friends so why don't you do something
about it of of every victim of these
drug overdose deaths attorney general
Garland said this is part of a
comprehensive strategy by the cartels to
flood these drugs into the United States
by overwhelming border patrol you're
clearly losing that battle
and you won't even apologize to these
parents like so many other parents who
have lost their teenage children to
counterfeit drugs laced with fentanyl we
are bringing unprecedented force in the
fight against and you're losing
let me ask you another question the
gravity of the challenge cannot be
overstated we recognize the gravity of
the challenge and I look forward to
working and you recognize that you were
losing I look forward to working with
you no that's not my question in this
committee
let me ask you another question in the
time remaining since you won't answer
our questions
and you won't acknowledge responsibility
my constituents are saying who's
accountable
who's accountable who's paying a price
who got fired
well you haven't been fired you should
be fired but you haven't been fired
because you were carrying out the
policies of the Biden Administration
and the we've seen
nothing but death and destruction
as a result
Senator the um
wait for a question
I recently went to the Yuma
border patrol sector
which is a sleepy little agricultural
Community as you know in southwest
Arizona
the border patrol Chief there greeted Us
by saying
we have
encountered
a hundred migrants from 176 countries
speaking 200 languages
Arizona Senator Mark Kelly pointed out
that Mexicali is a airport is a city
Northern Mexico with very close to the
Border where people can simply fly into
that and then take an Uber over to the
border patrol sector and claim Asylum
and then be released under your policies
under by demonstration policies into the
interior of the United States
from 176 different countries
recently I was in El Paso with a
bipartisan group of senators to that was
before we got to Yuma
and we were out on a night Patrol the
border patrol detained two young men who
were from the who had passports from the
People's Republic of China mainland
China controlled by the Chinese
Communist Party
they were presumably released like these
other individuals into the interior of
the United States with either a notice
to appear or a notice to report
can you tell the committee
where these people are today
can you assure us that these individuals
are not in the United States
to conduct espionage
or other nefarious acts against the
United States Government Can you
reassure us of that Senator if an
individual is deemed to present a threat
to Public Safety or national security
well how would individual how would you
know they show up at the passport and
they claim a credible fear of
persecution and then under yours and the
by Administration policies they're
released into the interior of the
country
these P these are people who perhaps we
don't have any records about certainly
we're not going to get them from China
you know zero about them and you know
zero about the threat they posed to the
United States and our national security
you can't tell us can you wear the
individuals are located who have been
either paroled or released into the
United States you have no no
comprehensive list or ability to
identify where those people are today do
you Senator let me let me again repeat
that we screen and vet individually
that's not my question
you're a you're a uh you're you're quite
capable of evading the questions we're
asking or diverting us to something else
that's not what we ask my question to
you is when somebody from the People's
Republic of China shows up in El Paso
Texas and then claims Asylum and is
released into the interior of the United
States do you know where they are and
what they are up to we very well can
know where they are based upon you can
do you it depends on the individual and
the fact though some of them if it
depends on the individual some of them
you don't don't know where they are or
what they are up to
is that right a senator the issue of
individuals absconding from law
enforcement isn't a challenge that and
you were failing in that challenge Mr
secretary you in the Biden
Administration policies are contributing
to what is happening on the border and
according to miss mcconville she
credited the Biden broken border
policies with contributing to the death
of her son and you won't even have the
common decency to apologize Senate
senator
as I mentioned before and I must say
this
that my heart is with the victims of
every
um
death from an overdose number one number
two we are bringing unprecedented Force
to the fight against the drug
traffickers number three the scourge of
fentanyl is not new it is not something
that was born in 2021 and I can provide
you with the tens of thousands of deaths
that preceded this Administration this
is a challenge that we all have to come
together to fight
he simply lost all credibility
Mr secretary
Senator Booker
thank you Mr chairman
the crisis offense and all has been
discussed a lot I want to Echo what my
colleagues on both sides of the aisle
have said in what you have said
this is an American crisis
it shouldn't divide us against each
other
we need to find where the common cause
and common urgency is and attack those
areas we should be guided by the facts
and the evidence
and not
the
typical political forces that divide us
that make it difficult to solve problems
we will not agree on everything but the
facts are the facts
this problem did not start under Joe
Biden
in fact Mr secretary
during the years of the Trump
Administration fentanyl deaths Rose in
America correct
uh yes they did that's all I need
this problem has risen under Republican
presidents and democratic presidents
this is not a partisan issue this is an
American issue this is an American
crisis
and more facts that I think are worthy
of repeating and saying clearly is
that this is an issue that is being
driven by criminals from our country
the data shows
that U.S citizens are accounting for 86
percent
of fentanyl trafficking convictions
86 percent
when I visited the Border
recently
down in Brownsville
the Customs and Border professionals
professionals every day that seek to
serve the security of this nation made
it very clear that this is
overwhelmingly Americans being stopped
coming through ports of Entry
that 91 percent of the fentanyl enters
our country through these ports of Entry
can you affirm that sir Senator is my
information indeed that the majority of
fentanyl coming into this country is
coming in through the ports of Entry uh
over 90 percent and American citizens of
the majority of people being arrested so
that is a a statistic with which I am
not familiar uh and um but certainly we
see American citizens uh as traffickers
in fentanyl as I referenced uh just a
few minutes ago yesterday I was a brief
most recently on Operation Blue Lotus
and indeed we apprehended for
prosecution to American citizens who
were trafficking in multi-kilograms of
fentanyl well sir I want to point out
that GAO report on June 22 June of 2022
which found that 91 percent of drug
seizures seizure events involve only U.S
citizens now this isn't to say that
undocumented immigrants are not a part
of the problem
they account for about nine percent
but we need to be operating on the facts
the guns that the cartels are using are
coming from where
a great number of them are coming from
the United States well give me can you
contextualize a great number is 20 30 or
the majority of the guns being used by
these cartels
coming from the United States or not yes
that is my understanding it is why
indeed we have surged resources uh to
interdict the flow of the illegal flow
of firearms to the South so to present
this as a problem
that is just a Mexico problem
and not discuss the facts that the
weapons of the cartels are using the
majority of according to your testimony
or coming from the United States
that the majority of the people we are
arresting coming across the border
trafficking that they're coming through
the ports of Entry means that we have to
look to solutions that meet the facts of
the crisis is that correct that is
correct
should this country
yeah
be
as as customers of border
agents told me and again these don't
sound like very politically
controversial issues
we need more resources at our borders
and our ports of Entry that enable
modern
Cutting Edge technology to be used to
detect the presence of fentanyl would
that help the problem yes it would
senator
and and I should say that we are
deploying an unprecedented level of
modern technology to interdict fentanyl
our non-intrusive inspection technology
is extraordinarily effective and we are
exploring the use of artificial
intelligence to serve as a force
multiplier I was in uh I was in Arizona
last week not only did I see the
non-intrusive inspection technology
which I've seen in many of my visits to
the Border I think I've made 16 as a
secretary but I also learn from our
colleagues about the forward operating
Labs that we now deploy to the ports of
Entry so Personnel expert in the
identification of the particular
narcotic at issue can analyze it confirm
its identity and bring the appropriate
prosecution to bear and so if there's an
action for Congress
that that could be a bipartisan effort
would be to Surge the resources to bet
further expand the cutting-edge
technology necessary to detect the
Fentanyl and to arrest the folks who are
trafficking that's a clear yes yes yes
that's all the second thing that
reminded me of my work doing law
enforcement in my city as mayor is that
we found that too many of our police
officers
were engaged in activities that weren't
the highest and best use when it came to
stopping and preventing crime
so again we need to protect our overall
border
and technology that was discussed with
me by Customs and Border control that
could use high tech sensory
all different types of of Technologies
from motion detectors to Aerial
surveillance they would tell me you
would free up considerable amounts of
our Customs and Border Patrol to focus
more on where exactly the fentanyl is
coming from
even more than that uh
when you have the a surge of Asylum
Seekers they were telling me stories
about too many of their Customs border
patrol simply doing data entry dealing
with the Asylum Seekers
as opposed to having those officers do
the things at the that what we know and
focusing on where we know the problem is
and so they talked about just simply
some of the things we did when I was
married at the city of North getting
civilians in to do the basic data entry
jobs
and and freeing up officers to focus on
ports of Entry where their highest and
best use is and so from the technology
to protect our border
to too many people sitting behind desks
with guns and officers do you agree with
me that we could be finding ways to
better use the Manpower woman power
person power that we have to to focus on
where the actual problem is
yes and we are doing that and let me let
me repeat very very briefly
um our use of Technology
uh and our exploration of AI artificial
intelligence as a force multiplier to
liberate some of our Personnel from some
of the more mundane tasks that could be
accomplished by so I would like to learn
more about that I have two minutes left
I really want to hear more about that
because when I was on the border I heard
from a lot of your agents the urgency to
do this I know you're making progress
and I'd like to hear more but I just and
we're also adding case processors to
make sure that the agents the uniformed
agents can be back out in the field we
have surged those research resources in
an unprecedented way there's always
going to be partisan differences there's
always going to be divisions in our
country but the lines that divide us are
nowhere near as strong as the ties that
bind us we all care we all are having
people dying in our communities people
we know families we meet with
and yet there's so much room for us to
work together where we agree and get
things done and support the agents on
the ground that when I meet with them
they're some of the proudest most
dedicated patriotic Americans in the in
the few seconds I have left sir last
week the Anti-Defamation League released
its annual report examining anti-semitic
incidents according to the ADL in 2022
there were at least
3697 anti-semitic incidents throughout
the United States this is a 36 percent
increase
from the 2717 incidents tabulated in
it's the highest number on record since
the ADLs are tracking anti-Semitism is
at a stunning rise and the highest we're
ever detecting
this is to me absolutely frightening the
number one targeted religious group in
our country
I know the Department of Homeland
Security released a tool kit for
communities to better understand how to
how to protect themselves I think it's a
valuable resource
but could you please just in the last 30
seconds I have how is the department
approaching Community to driven
solutions to the kind of violent
extremism
that threatens
Jewish Americans sick Americans Muslim
Americans that are beginning to to to
have
so many of our religious minorities
being targeted in the United States in
the 10 seconds that I have disseminating
information so everyone is aware of the
threat providing advice with respect to
the hardening of vulnerable locations
providing 20 million dollars in Grant
funds each year to allow places of
worship uh religious schools
community-based organizations to
increase their level of security this
requires a whole of community approach
and our our Center for prevention
programs and Partnerships is
extraordinarily devoted to that well we
have more to do collectively as a
Congress and in your agency more must be
done hate has no Harbor in the United
States of America these incidents are on
a rise and I would ask my colleagues for
all of us to do more in partnership with
those who are protecting us in our
communities to address the scourge of
anti-Semitism and violence against
religious minorities in our country
thank you thank you thank you Senator
Booker Senator Lee
thank you Mr chairman thank you
secretary mayorkas for being here
I'm troubled by a number of things
including some exchanges you had a few
minutes ago with a couple of my
colleagues
one in particular dealing with your
definition of operational control it
wouldn't trouble me quite the same way
that it does but for the fact that this
isn't just a casual term of art that
people throw around it's nor is it a
term that that made its first appearance
uh with your service at the Department
of Homeland Security this is a
statutorily defined term of Art
and and Congress has defined it now for
the last 17 years is involving the the
prevention of all unlawful entries into
the United States
so it appears to me that you your
definition which has to do with
maximizing resources uh it
distorts this it it appears to me to be
something that is perhaps an intentional
effort to obfuscate the real problem to
hide the absolute humanitarian and legal
disaster that we have unfolding on our
Southern border one with massive
National Security implications and human
health implications as we've seen 110
000 Americans die from fentanyl just
last year all that fentanyl by the way
comes from Mexico it's no mystery where
it's coming from it's not made here not
even made in China anymore the stuff
that shows up here it's made in Mexico
um so
perhaps this redefinition helps hide
that helps obscure it
but it still doesn't help look this is
making it worse the what you're doing is
making a lot of things worse
and I'm concerned that this shows up in
a number of areas I'm going to talk
about some of those today uh shows up in
your use of parole it shows up on issues
related to Asylum and it shows up in
issues related to the Detention of of
Asylum applicants let's talk about uh
parole first
in one of these efforts to disguise the
political impact to diffuse the
political impact and disguise what's
actually happening
you've started to rename things and
Rebrand them
so that the numbers seem to be improving
more than they actually are but they
aren't
uh
it's come to my attention that you've
created at least 13 new parole programs
within the Department of Homeland
Security
now I find this odd because you
you break by things like country of
origin
um but I find this odd because
the statute itself
creating parole which is found in eight
USC 1182 d5a
says that the Secretary of Homeland
Security subject to certain conditions
uh uh shall parole May parole into the
United States temporarily under such
conditions as he may prescribe only on a
case-by-case basis for Urgent
humanitarian reasons or a significant
public benefit any alien applying for
admission to the United States so
Congress went way out of its way
to Define that and to say this must be
handled on a case-by-case basis no broad
grants of these are the kinds of people
who are going to parole in
um now what qualifies as an urgent
humanitarian reason or a significant
public benefit in your view seems to be
anything that will appear to reduce
regular immigration this is so far
afield from the definition that Congress
actually authorized by Statute uh and
far beyond what it's uh heretofore been
understood to do and what the words
themselves mean which is to provide
a a way that somebody could come in in
the case of the uh of a medical
emergency
under that portion of the statutory
language or for example someone who is
coming in on the under the public
benefit prong from a foreign country
who's needed to testify in in a jury
trial or something like that and then be
returned
parole wasn't intended to be broad nor
was it intended to provide someone a
permanent residence or a residence that
can become permanent within the United
States
and so this is really concerning to me
when we see this I wonder how you can
possibly defend the legality of this it
shows up further
in the way that you're handling it
Asylum let me ask you this Mr secretary
does anyone coming into our border have
a right to Asylum or is this rather a
grant of discretion to you as the
Secretary of Homeland Security to Grant
it where you deem appropriate under the
circumstances prescribed by the law
um currently
Senator we are exercising the public
health authority of title 42 and under
title 42 a claim of Asylum cannot be
made the individual is expelled under
that public health authority and
irrespective of the fact so let's put
that aside I know you want to talk about
title 42 title 42 is going away so then
an individual who arrives at our border
may claim
uh fear of persecution by reason of
their membership in a particular social
group I get that I know the standard I'm
asking you is it a right or is it an act
of discretion on your part because
remember the language says
the secretary May
grant them Asylum
may may is not shall so is it
discretionary or is it mandatory on your
part we we have the ability to make a
discretionary decision with respect to
the grant of Asylum based upon the
factors that we evaluate okay
um now
I I have something to say about parole
but perhaps sure I've got time to that I
want to talk about this uh first with in
the your exchange with one of my
colleagues I think it may have been
Senator Graham earlier uh you seem to
concede at least for purposes of
discussion that most Asylum applicants
don't get in and that the main number
may be something like 9 out of ten who
don't get in I know it varies from
country to Country uh uh but but uh it's
more or less uh nine out of ten or some
large number some large percentage of
Asylum applicants are not eligible to
come in is that right it that that is
correct that that the number who qualify
under the initial threshold of credible
fear is larger than the number of
individuals who actually ultimately
succeed in their final Asylum
adjudication right
in fact federal law that's that's
purposeful by design of the statutory
framework
under eight USC section 1225 B1 an alien
awaiting an asylum determination a a
ruling on his or her Asylum application
uh is subject to mandatory detention
it says that the alien shall be detained
pending a final determination of
credible fear
of persecution and if found not to have
such fear uh until removed
um and yet um you're not currently
detaining all Asylum applicants are you
um Senator I believe this this very
issue uh is the subject of ongoing
litigation I will only say this
therefore that that the Department of
Homeland Security specifically
Immigration and Customs Enforcement has
never had the detention capacity to
detain I'm not every Asylum Seeker I I'm
not asking whether you've got that
detention they have in the past I'm
asking what is supposed to happen and
the the truth is under the statutory
provision I just read to you you're
supposed to detain them
and yet you don't and as far as running
out of detention capacity
you are in fact getting rid of detention
space
are you not as reported by Fox News just
yesterday I and and what about the fact
that uh no an ice detention budget has
been slashed by this Administration to
the tune of hundreds of millions of
dollars Senator we're not reducing the
amount of detention space I don't know
to uh to what that report
um refers as a matter I'm not sure what
that reporter refers to we're not
diminishing the amount of detention
space right now you are not deporting
people once you reach your cap of the
detention space and that is a problem
because you you've said time and time
again in front of this Committee in
another context you and other members of
this Administration have said over and
over again that the system has broken
the process is broken the the law is
broken and then you blame it on Congress
well
maybe that's good if what you're wanting
to do is advocate for you know some kind
of Reform that involves amnesty but it's
just not true as far as the Asylum
process because if the Asylum process
were followed by the law
you would turn people away you would
send them back once you ran out of
detention space you detained those where
you're supposed to detain and then you'd
send the rest back and this is a big
problem look I'm running out of time uh
I am concerned about another thing a
number of things that I'll follow up
with questions for the record but a
couple of closing issues uh just in
short first I'm very concerned about
your Office of Intelligence and Analysis
uh there's been a a letter sent to you
by the house Homeland Security committee
that you have not answered when they do
answer that I I would love to get those
answers those responses and I would also
like a briefing on this
in the very near future we need to know
what's in there look at the end of the
day
it appears to me that you were not
enforcing the law you were redefining
key statutory terms in order to
obfuscate the fact that you're not
enforcing the law
this is a fireable offense
and an enormous amount of money
preparing
for impeachment proceedings like three
million dollars preparing for
impeachment proceedings could it be
perhaps that they know that you have
been doing this that you've been
redefining statutory terms failing to
enforce the law
that seems removable to me thank you
Senator I respectfully disagree with you
and I look forward to the opportunity to
addressing your concerns
thank you Senator Lee Senator Klobuchar
thank you very much if I can make an
announcement after Senator Klobuchar
there'll be a 10-minute break so we have
a roll call on the floor some members
may want to take advantage of it now I'm
going to be one of them Senator
Klobuchar is recognized okay very good
uh thank you Mr chair uh thank you so
much Mr secretary I'm going to actually
take a different approach here at the
beginning I do have some question about
fentanyl Center capital and I are
introducing a bill on it today my state
has the lowest unemployment rate in the
country I don't know if you know that a
number of the states of senators and
this committee have a lot of unfilled
jobs in their states and part of this is
apprenticeships and getting people
directed to those jobs but part of it is
also immigration and you and I have
talked about this before I first of all
want to thank you for the work that's
been done on the Commerce side on the
longest border in the world with Canada
that would be my state
um and uh the work that we have 5 500
Mile Border in the U.S uh with Canada
and
um we had many issues during the
pandemic a lot of those have now gone
away I was just met with a number of the
leaders in Parliament there on Friday as
part of the summit between President
Biden and prime minister Trudeau
including liberal and conservative
members of parliament and we agreed that
there have been improvements on that
front and of course there's been the
issue that was agreed to between the two
heads of state about
concerns On the Border cross-border
smuggling operations Senator Blackburn
and I are putting forward a bill on that
but can you talk about the steps the
department has taken and plans to
address smuggling of both people and
narcotics across the northern border
Senator thank you very much for your
concern
um I know you're very well aware of the
announcement that we made last week with
respect to the safe Third Country
agreement uh with Canada to ensure that
we're fortifying uh the land of the
Borderland in between the ports of Entry
we were very proud to move that
regulation through uh in with
extraordinary speed we are focused
intensely on all our borders not just
the southern border but our Maritime
borders and our northern border as well
I just recently spoke with the
commissioner the acting Commissioner of
U.S Customs and Border Protection with
respect to the deployment of personnel
to the northern border precisely to
address the concerns that you have
expressed okay very good
um
um going beyond Canada
um I will ask on the record some
questions about work authorizations for
ukrainians many of us on this committee
are very involved in the effort in
Ukraine but we also know we have people
here that want to work who are
temporarily
refugees in our country and I want to
thank you for the work that's been
um get done on that front I'll ask you
some questions on the record about how
the policy is gone
um I mentioned our Workforce shortage if
we were hiring tomorrow we have about
139 000 unfilled positions one of these
Solutions as you know in addition to
comprehensive reform I've joined a
bipartisan group of senators including
King rounds hickenloop or barasso in
calling on the department to release the
maximum allowable number of h-2b visas
to help get the workers they need could
you talk about how your experience how
h2b guest worker programs have helped
address Workforce shortages yes Senator
so we issued the maximum number of h2b
visas this year in addition I exercised
the secretary's discretionary Authority
and released the maximum additional
number of visas available and we did so
earlier than ever before precisely
because of the demand for labor uh that
we in this country have I believe the
chairman referred uh to 11 million uh
job vacancies
um and so we're very mindful of that
unfortunately our immigration system is
not well designed to address the need
for labor it is our hope that reform
actually is uh legislated uh to address
that issue right you know and I always
picture some of the agreements that
sadly we were not able to get past one
passed in the Senate when Senator
Grassley was actually the Republican
leader of the committee but it is some
combination of Border resources on the
Southern and I would add Northern
borders as well as the increase in the
Caps of these type of workers as well as
green card
citizenship issues especially for our
dreamers and some of those and I add
into that group uh Afghans as you know
um more than 75 000 Afghans sought
refuge in our country I'd say about half
of them have literal letters from our
chief of mission and our military
vouching for them they stood by our
soldiers our military VFW American
Legion All believe we cannot leave these
people in limbo and many of our
Republican colleagues that are
supportive of our efforts focus on the
fact that we can do more vetting this
way these are people who are in our
country Senator wicker and Moran and
um of course
Senator Graham the ranking member of
this committee have been part of our
efforts on The Afghan Refugee and have
signed their name on this bill and we're
working with other Senators as we speak
and our bipartisan legislation that I
know you're aware of requires applicants
to go through vetting that is just as
rigorous as the vetting they would have
gone through if they came as refugees as
Stan under that eight former Republican
Administration National Security
officials called the gold standard of
vetting and so we have worked with your
department and DOD on this how would the
vetting Provisions included in the
Afghan adjustment help to ensure that
Afghan evacuees are fully and rigorously
vetted Senator we're very um
appreciative of that act and we do hope
it is promulgated in operation allies
welcome our effort to bring Afghan
Nationals who stood by us
in combat safely to the United States we
undertook a rigorous screening and
vetting protocol and we did that before
they arrived to the fullest extent
possible this act a really
institutionalizes that process and also
provides stability for those Afghan
Nationals who are here in the United
States and provides them with a critical
path forward very good I'm going to end
here with a series of questions on
fentanyl I know you've been asked this
by my colleagues but I want to look at
Solutions we've lost like everyone else
here many people in our state to this
Scourge Senator Portman and I passed the
stop act to require that international
mail include Advanced electronic data
that CBP can use to stop fentanyl
Fentanyl and at least use that because
as you know there's issues with the
actual mail
could you talk about what difference
that has made I'm going to just combine
these questions so you can secondly in
2021 there were more than a hundred
thousand drug overdoses in the U.S
and Center capital and I have urged the
department to prioritize investigations
into fentanyl trafficking on the dark
web which is another part of the problem
it's the mail it's the dark web and then
also
this week I introduced a bill with
Senator Scott to allow military veterans
to be trained as investigators through
the DHS Heroes Corps program to conduct
investigations into fentanyl trafficking
online another piece of the Cyber part
of this could you talk about the Cyber
piece of this as well as the male piece
of it because I know you've gotten at
other issues with our colleagues Senator
your your questions go to a the
significance of the challenge that we
face because it is not just through the
land ports of entry and certainly not
just by land but it is by mail the dark
web the internet pose Marketplace
challenges for the illegal trafficking
of these incredibly dangerous uh fatal
narcotics the the stock Act is a
critical tool to allow us to pre-screen
to be aware of any anomalies information
that will assist us in the interdiction
of uh Contraband coming in through our
mail system it's been of tremendous
utility to U.S Customs and Border
Protection
with respect to
um fentanyl trafficking the dark web is
a Marketplace not only for fentanyl but
for other heinous crimes we're seeing
such an increase for example in online
child sexual exploitation uh here again
are incredible Special Agents of
Homeland Security investigations along
with our special agents of the United
States Secret Service are doing
extraordinary work in an all of
administration effort we are very
appreciative of your Heroes Act and the
use of military veterans capable
individuals who've served our country so
nobly to work with us in battling the
online proliferation of Narcotics and
other Contraband and other illegal acts
all right very good well thank you for
your service and you're happy to hear my
next question would you like to be part
of our 10-minute recess that the
committee will now take
I think I will be okay very good
committee will now take a 10-minute
recess thank you
foreign
thank you
equal space
foreign
all right
okay
no
yes
again sometimes
um
foreign
meeting will resume I thank Senator
Klobuchar for helping we have one more
roll call vote on the floor so members
may be coming and going but at this
point recognize Senator Cruz
good morning secretary mayorkas good
morning
is there a crisis at our Southern border
Senator there is a very that's a yes or
no question is it very significant is
there a crisis
Senator there's a very significant
challenge I think your microphone is not
on
there is a very significant challenge
that we are facing yes or no is there a
crisis I believe I've addressed that
question so you're refusing to answer
Senator there is a very significant
Challenge and will you answer if there's
a crisis therefore we are dedicating the
resources okay so you're refusing to
answer well secretary mayorkas I'll tell
you someone who is willing to answer
which is your and President Biden's
chief of the border patrol in a sworn
deposition in July of 2022 when asked
would you agree Chief Ortiz that the
southern border is currently in crisis
answer yes notice none of those wiggle
words none of that equivocation one word
one syllable yes are you willing to
speak with the same clarity as Chief
Ortiz is there a crisis at our Southern
border yes or no Senator I'm very proud
to work alongside well you refuse to
answer let me ask you the next question
has the crisis at our Southern border
made Americans less safe yes or no
Senator we are dedicated to the safety
has the crisis made Americans less safe
I don't I don't want a discourse it's a
yes or no question
Senator we have a challenge you refuse
to answer the questions SEC Mr secretary
let me show you how someone doing his
job answers a question in a
straightforward manner Chief Ortiz
is the crisis that is currently ongoing
at the southern border making the Border
less safe for Americans and Aliens alike
answer yes one word one syllable three
letters that's how someone answers a
question and does their job you're being
a politician misleading the American
people let me give you a chance again
will you show the same Integrity Chief
Ortiz shows is the crisis at the
southern border making Americans less
safe yes or no Senator we have 260
thousand you refuse to answer the
question let's move on and security next
question Mr mayorkas has the crisis made
aliens less safe yes or no
Senator we are seeking so you won't
answer that question either it is it's a
yes or no has it made aliens less safe
Senator Smugglers are exploiting has the
crisis made aliens yes less safe are you
willing to answer it
Senator the smuggling organizations okay
you're filibustering again let me ask
you this question
how many migrants have died under
President Biden
Senator your your phrasing of the
question is actually quite misleading
how many migrants died in 2022
um uh at our approaching our Southern
border yes precisely why we are seeking
to accept do you know the answer do you
know how many died I do not you do not
of course you don't I know how many died
853. that is 853 and by the way here are
the numbers that have died every year
you go back to 1998 you see it's
consistently between 300 and 400 304 to
300 400. suddenly 2021 what happens you
get in office and that red line are dead
bodies I've been on the Rio Grande and
I've seen dead bodies floating there
who've drowned
because of your refusal to do your job
you don't even know how many have died
what do you say to the Texas farmers and
ranchers who find pregnant ladies dead
on their property who find toddlers dead
on their property what do you say to
them I say that is why precisely we are
taking it to the smuggling organization
but you are not that is simply not true
number two Let Me
read Journal
The Wall Street Journal two weeks ago
ran an article entitled it's like great
a graveyard record numbers of migrants
are dying at the border The Story begins
with this chilling Line quote
Eagle Pass Texas
local officials keep a refrigerated
truck to hold the bodies of migrants who
drown in the currents of the Rio Grande
while trying to cross the border into
the U.S Mr chairman I ask unanimous
consent that this article be entered
into the record
let me ask you a different question
how many children
have been sexually assaulted by human
traffickers
under the Biden Administration Senator
this is precisely why we Institute I
don't want a lecture it's a question how
many children have been sexually
assaulted by human traffickers under
your Administration Senator this is this
is exactly why on January 5th again do
you know how many do you know how many
children have been sexually assaulted
this is why we say you're going to
refuse to answer that question as well
let's move on it's obvious you've been
instructed to Stonewall
so I'm not going to let you you don't
get the Stonewall and filibuster now one
of my Democratic colleagues before said
the Democrat talking point quote this
problem didn't start under Biden
that's I look I get if you're a partisan
spinner you got to figure out something
to say about the absolute catastrophe
that has played out under the Biden
Administration true or false secretary
Marcus 2020
was the lowest rate of illegal
immigration in 45 years is that true or
false
it is certainly the lowest level of
immigration in many many years and what
was it okay fine 2020. what was it
senator in 2020 that impacted the entire
world including the United States okay
so your testimony is the reason we had
the lowest rate was covet it had nothing
to do with building the wall nothing to
do with any Catch and Release nothing to
do with remain in Mexico with all
respect Mr secretary that answer is
laughable and in fact if you look
add illegal immigration let's look at
CBP encounters you can see five hundred
thousand five hundred thousand it drops
to the lowest level and boom what
happens you show up and that red line is
you
that red line is Joe Biden and you're
claiming nothing happened oh gosh this
was here before us no you made the
decision to allow this to happen let me
ask you we now have over 5.5 million
people who've entered this country
illegally under Joe Biden how many
murderers Have You released into America
Senator I'm not aware of any murder whom
we've so you don't know
Senator let me say something do you know
if you take a look at no no you don't
get to give a speech do you know how
many murders I'm just trying to answer
your question how many rapists Have You
released Senator I'm trying do you know
you can answer I know or I don't know
Senator any individual who poses a
public safety threat how many child
molesters Have You released and removed
into the United States from the United
States so your testimony under oath
subject to perjury is that you have not
released any murderers rapist or child
molesters among the 5.5 million is that
your testimony
um Mr chairman may I have the
opportunity no you may not you may
answer my question
is that your testimony yes or no Senator
you're not allowing me to answer you I
am allowing you to answer I'm not
allowing you to feel about if you take a
look at the the pace of immigration in
2018 to 2019 you're refusing to answer
let's move on let's move on to God aways
godaways are the people that get away
that you know about now what happened
under your Administration God always
consistently down at this low line boom
you get in and they go from below 180
000 to 600 000. now I'll tell you this
about it got away you don't know among
those 600 000 a year you have no idea
how many are murderers correct that is
precisely why do you know how many of
those are murderers that is precisely so
you refuse to answer the question you
know how many are rapists
do you know how many are rapist this is
a question you're a lawyer you know how
to answer questions of the six hundred
thousand do you know how many of them
were rapists Senator this is why so
again the answer is no let me ask you
this do you know how many of them are
terrorists and I don't want to Senator
here's my lecture on this do you know
how many of the six hundred thousand
gotaways were terrorists yes or no
Senator we are focused on this you
refuse to answer that as well
what's the result
of massive godaways well one of the
results is drug overdoses and we now
have last year
over a hundred thousand overdoses
who died the majority from Chinese
fentanyl streaming across the border
now you told Senator cornyn you care but
look what has happened under your policy
when you open up the border to the worst
illegal immigration our nation's history
people die
you claim you care
Mr secretary
that is a lie you know some months ago
Kareem Jean-Pierre stood up at a White
House briefing and said people are not
just walking across the border
was she telling the truth
Senator you are was she telling you so
profoundly disrespectful was she telling
the truth two years okay you get to
answer questions you don't need to give
speeches Senator I served as a federal
prosecutor all right you're refusing to
answer if you look at she was lying and
she was not lying on her own she was
lying on behalf of the president of the
United States now uh the photograph of
people
walking
she was lying on behalf of the president
of the United States this is a
photograph from Just One Day along the
Rio Grande of hundreds of thousands of
people walking across the border you
have allowed this to happen the
photograph that was before
what what are these wristbands
I don't know what they are you don't
know what they are
Mr secretary you've just testified to
the American people you're incompetent
at your job because I've been to the
southern border and if you go to the
southern border along the southern
border you see thousands of these
wristbands because the illegal
immigrants wear them the drug cartels
every color corresponds to how many
thousands of dollars they owe the
cartels you have turned these cartels
into multi-billion dollar criminal
organizations and these are modern day
leg irons because these are children
being sold into sex slavery and you
don't even know what they are that is
astonishing Mr secretary how many
children have been sold into sex slavery
under your Administration Senator we are
taking it to the cartel how many
children have been sold into sex slavery
do you know how many children have been
sold into sex slavery to an
unprecedented degree Mr secretary I want
to say to you right now your behavior is
disgraceful and the deaths the children
assaulted the children raped they are at
your feet and if you had Integrity you
would resign
and I will tell you the men and women of
the border patrol they've never had a
political leader undermine them they
despise you Mr secretary because you're
willing to let children be raped
to follow political orders this is a
crisis it's a disgrace and you won't
even admit this human tragedy is a
crisis
foreign
Mr secretary would you like to respond
to any of those questions what the
senator said was revolting I'm not going
to address it
your refusal to do your job is revolta
thank you Mr chairman uh obviously you
think it's uh
disrespectful the treatment that we've
just seen the secretary undergo I think
it's respectful to suggest or imply that
a chat that the root causes of a broken
immigration system are so simple that
they can be answered in two and a half
seconds or less uh
that the solutions necessary to
improve our immigration system for the
needs of today and the future could be
delivered in two and a half seconds or
less so let me for the moment uh
continue some questions all the subject
matters that a republican colleagues
keep bringing up over and over and over
again and we'll we'll stay on fentanyl
for a second uh correct me if I'm wrong
Mr secretary but I think Senator Booker
earlier mentioned that in 2021 it's been
found that U.S citizens accounted for
more than 86 percent of convicted
fentanyl drug traffickers does that
sound about right to you Senator as I
mentioned too Senator Booker I'm not
familiar with that statistical or
certainly aware of the fact that
American citizens are participating in
the trafficking of illegal in our
clients that I've seen do documented the
vast majority of those bring fentanyl
into the country our United States
citizens not the migrants that our
colleagues the other side of the aisle
will are implying also that nearly you
know 99 to the consumers who are paying
for illicit opioids so we can look at
both ends of this right who's driving
the demand not just who may be
responsible for the supply
um
statistic again from federal agencies
point zero two percent of the people
arrested by a border patrol for crossing
the border illegally
possessed Fentanyl at the time
more than 90 percent of the fentanyl
brought into this country is brought in
through the ports of Entry I cannot
overstate the viciousness and cruelty of
the smuggling organizations it's
precisely why we are building safe
orderly and lawful Pathways for people
to come to the United States and if they
are eligible and cutting out the
smuggling organs and that's the point
I'm trying to get to Mr secretary I want
to sort of level set sort of reality
check the conversation because the
challenge is a serious one it should be
approached with seriousness and maturity
so now that we've caught our breath from
the prior exchange I want to afford you
an opportunity to speak into the
administration's approach the
significance of a whole of government
approach to the problem not just all of
federal government but any uh
Partnerships real or potential that you
think can be value added here I know in
the state of California for example
state resources are being committed to
augment additional screening equipment
and other technologies that can help in
this cause in a productive manner so so
two different parts so Senator and I
appreciate the opportunity the the the
administration's approach uh to the
migration challenge which is quite
serious and it is one that is not
exclusive to the United States but is
gripping the entire region there are
approximately 2.5 million Venezuelans in
Colombia now there is an unprecedented
movement of people throughout the
hemisphere our approach is to cut out
the Smugglers who are indeed vicious and
cruel and to build safe lawful and
orderly paths for people to arrive in
the United States and on January 5th we
announced a parole program for Cubans
Haitians nicaraguans and Venezuelans
that they could apply
for entry into the United States in a
safe and orderly way and we would
deliver consequences if they arrive
irregularly in between our ports of
Entry at the southern border we have
seen a 95 percent drop in the number of
Encounters of those four nationalities
in between our ports of Entry people
will take advantage of a safe lawful and
orderly path if it is presented to them
and we are cutting out the smuggling
organizations precisely for the reasons
that Senator Cruz mentioned with respect
to fentanyl we are bringing the fight to
the cartels in an unprecedented way we
have surged resources most recently in
Operation Blue Lotus which is already
demonstrating significant results we are
using our Personnel our extraordinary
Personnel we are using technology we are
using everything that we can bring to
bear to fight the scourge of Fentanyl
and other synthetic opioids we are also
questing of Congress additional
resources so that we can enhance that
fight we need to work together to
address a challenge that precedes this
Administration
and we need to work on it together it is
something that is killing far too many
Americans I agree thank you and as you
know there's many of the uh ideas
proposals that uh you and the White
House have suggested that I agree with
and support and several that have been
proposed or suggested that I don't agree
with them we're having those
constructive mature conversations I want
to make sure to touch space on a couple
of other important issues including
um the shelter and Services Program I
was pleased to leave there for last year
to ensure there was adequate funding for
the program which was formerly known as
the emergency food and shelter program
program that allows reimbursements for
non-governmental organizations and local
entities that provide shelter
transportation and other services to
migrants at the border again security
and Humanity uh in the process it was
previously housed under FEMA now the
program is under CBP so I just raised it
to acknowledge this transition and
formally request regular updates on the
implementation of the new program to
ensure that the entities that rely on
these funds to play that supportive role
that they have been can continue to
access the funds that we make available
I appreciate your support of that
program the funding is critically needed
we have funded the emergency food and
shelter program with 350 million dollars
of the 800 million and of course we are
standing up the SSP at the it's known by
its acronym
and once that has stood up of course we
will we will be funding that with the
balance of the 800 million and
distributing it to cities for their care
of individuals here next topic and next
issue something that we've had a couple
conversations about in 2022 the Army
struggled to meet its recruiting goal of
enlisting sixty thousand soldiers it
only enlisted 45
000 that year as our Armed Forces
collectively look for ways to
incentivize enlistment one way that's
the only way but one way that has worked
throughout our nation's history is to
ask immigrants who in enlist or to
ensure that immigrants to enlists are
able to become citizens uh quickly as
specified in the immigration and
nationality Act
I understand that since July the USCIS
and the Department of Defense began to
work on a memorandum of agreement to
formalize their partnership and to
coordinate services for members of the
military to naturalize early in their
military careers uh when do you expect
that mou to be finalized and what
tangible steps can we take to improve
the Naturalization rates of military
service members uh Senator thank you
very much for that it is um uh
remarkable that individuals have been
willing to serve in our Armed Forces
before they have become citizens we've
made tremendous progress with the
Department of Defense to allow
individuals to naturalize who are
serving in our Armed Forces at an
earlier stage and we're going to be
moving quickly on that now we had a very
significant development yesterday on
that
thank you look forward to uh working
with you on that as well and in my time
remaining I just wanted to uh
acknowledge earlier uh in the hearing
you brought up FEMA actually in your
opening statement uh with the
appropriate attention to Mississippi
where the tornadoes and their impact are
dominating the national news right now
but I also feel a responsibility to
remind my colleagues and you and the
country about the California communities
who continue to experience an onslaught
of of a devastating atmospheric rivers
and the devastation in the wake of
recent storms entire communities have
been flooded Farms are underwater
thousands of of families being evacuated
from their homes and many who will not
be able to return to work anytime soon
or return to their home anytime soon and
I want to specifically call attention to
the community of bajaru which is a small
low-income predominantly Farm worker
community that has for decades
been overlooked by FEMA and frankly
agencies at all levels of uh government
but specifically the Trump era
individual assistance regulation uh
under FEMA is exacerbating the hardship
California struggled to meet FEMA
thresholds for Disaster Assistance
because the regulation established a new
Factor called the state fiscal capacity
and resource availability to be
considered when FEMA evaluates the need
for individual assistance so this isn't
the public assistance for communities
cities municipalities Etc to rebuild
we're talking individual assistance here
the rule has resulted in significant
disparities and inequities
it's left out disaster virus like those
in Grizzly Flats you know suffer from
wildfires just a couple years ago
without the support they need
communities like this continue to wait
in limbo as California waits to tally up
more and more damage than other states
just to get the same level of federal
assistance so I wanted to put that on
your radar I'm sure we'll continue to
talk about this in his gak in the coming
weeks but we have to fix these clear
inequities and federal guidelines and
regulations thank you Mr secretary thank
you Mr chair thank you forward to
following up with you Senator thanks
Senator Padilla Senator Hawley
thank you Mr chairman Mr secretary thank
you for being here let me start with
what I hope is a simple question do we
need to have more or fewer people coming
to our Southern border
a Senator Senator we are working on
diminishing the number of people whom we
encounter at our Southern border because
of the challenge it presents we're
trying to build lawful safe and orderly
Pathways to accomplish that okay fewer
so we need to have fewer which means we
need to roll back incentives to come
so I I would have I would have thought
that would have been the answer let's
talk about what you're doing though in
January of this year you rolled out a
new phone app called CBP one an app for
a cell phone
I've got a picture of it behind me here
this phone app
allows and I'm going to quote from your
own fact sheet it allows and I quote
non-citizens without appropriate
documents for admission
to schedule an appointment to come to
the Border
they can now go on their phone and
schedule a time to come to the border
and then be admitted
and you identified seven separate border
points of Entry where they could come
five of them in Texas two of them in
California one in Arizona it's like a
concierge service for illegal immigrants
my question is you didn't think the
Border crisis was bad enough that now
we're going to have an app that allows
illegals to schedule their appointments
and come and be admitted to this country
uh Senator you're mischaracterizing the
use of the application let me let me
explain it to you we are currently
enforcing the public health order of
title 42 and I know you're very familiar
with it there is a process for
individuals who claim an exception to
the title 42 expulsion Authority because
of an acute medical
condition well let's talk about this app
if I may finish an urgent
um an urgent humanitarian reason so
instead of them coming in between the
ports of Entry to claim that urgent
medical condition that extraordinarily
acute humanitarian cause we allow a
limited number to arrive at our ports of
entry and seek the emergency relief that
they need schedule you you allow them
let's let's be let's be particular about
what you should say CBP one app was not
uh unveiled for the first time on
January 5th of this year oh no but you
changed it you made it available on
January 5th to the illegals themselves
you don't have to be a lawyer to use it
you don't have to be a member of a
non-governmental organization anybody
can download the app and use it on their
phone and for the first time you allowed
them to schedule appointments now let's
talk about what actually happens when
they come to the Border it's interesting
you characterize this when you rolled it
out as an application for applying for
Asylum but nowhere on the app do you
actually require the illegal migrants to
apply for Asylum or to claim Asylum or
anything about Asylum and in fact when
they then get to the Border you don't
ask them questions you don't do
interviews you just release them here's
the Texas monthly not a notable
conservative Outlet who reports and I
quote at no point does the app ask user
are you seeking Asylum those arriving
for the cbp1 appointments are given no
interviews asked no questions about
vulnerabilities that they may or may not
have listed in the app or about why
they're coming to the United States
they're simply released into the country
end quote so rather than building a wall
Mr secretary you have built Ticketmaster
for illegal immigrants you are Senator
you are conflating programs let me let
me explain just just respond to this is
it true that they are given no
interviews ask no questions and simply
released into the country let me explain
to you what we announced on January 5th
no I want to explain to me what's
happening I know what you announced I
read it to you so I so I will explain to
you what is happening are they giving
interviews let's start with that are
they given interviews we were previously
experiencing almost starting to sound
like a no well let's just let's just
hone in here Mr secretary my time is is
very limited I don't mean to interrupt
you but I want to drive to some clarity
here are the Texas monthly has reported
that once illegal immigrants go on their
phone and Reserve their time to come to
the Border once they use your concierge
service that you've created for them
when they come they are given no
interviews they are asked no questions
about any vulnerabilities they are
simply released into the country is that
happening uh Senator you are mistaken
and if I may explain are they given
interviews if I may explain individuals
who seek parole
under our January 5th program for Cubans
Haitians nicaraguans and Venezuelans are
screened and vetted before they arrive
at our border wait a minute wait a
minute no no they go on and they go on
the phone and they just reserve a time
and then they show up and they're not
given they're given nothing listen to
this even immigration Advocates are
amazed about this here also from the
Texas monthly here's one immigration
Advocate whose first name is orda she
says that's the crazy part nothing in
this new program requires you to
actually seek Asylum somehow we've
decided to punish those who arrive at
the border without the app who may be
seeking Asylum but we just let in
anybody who may or may not have any
particular reason to seek Asylum so long
as they've made an appointment on your
Ticketmaster app this seems crazy to me
Senator it's a complete
mischaracterization of the program that
we announced and are implementing so how
many people have used how many people
have used the app then you are referring
to so if I can explain how many people
have used the app so we have
um we had a significant surge of Cubes
how many people have used the app
nicaraguan's invented Mr secretary
you're here to answer my questions how
many people have used the app uh tens of
thousands have sought to make an
appointment at the Port of Entry under
our parole program okay okay good how
many have been admitted
without an interview at the border
um well uh you are again inserting a
fact that does not belong in your
question so if I can I will get you the
person I'm reading to you from public
reports about how your own app works
you're just blanket denied so you're not
quite denying it you're saying that
maybe we don't understand apparently I
don't understand Texas monthly doesn't
understand immigration Advocates don't
understand you're the only one who
understands it you won't answer my
question how much did this cost to
develop by the way
Senator I don't have the cost but let me
share with you a critical will you get
it for us let me share with you a
critical will you get us the cost of
what it to develop this app did you use
a did you contract with the tech firm to
develop it
um Senator we have seen a approximately
did you contract with the tech firm to
develop it we have seen an approximately
five percent did you contract with a
tech firm to develop it yes or no
Senator this was led by U.S Customs and
Border Protection our technical experts
within the agency and I certainly will
get an answer to your question whether
outside Consultants were utilized you
don't know development process you don't
know may I may I explain to you since
you have a misunderstanding of the
program what it is and the impact the
positive impact it has had on Encounters
of these four populations in between I
just want to know why it is that you are
allowing people to come to this border
to make appointments to not be
interviewed and then how many have just
been released is it true by the way as
the Texas monthly reports that they're
simply released into the country on
official parole and get this they're not
given according to their reporting any
kind of follow-up their court dates are
in Immigration courts Texas monthly
reports not even necessarily Asylum
trials they're often General deportation
hearings where defendants can make
Arguments for remaining in the country
is that true that is um uh completely
mistaken understanding of how the
immigration process works that language
is completely confusing and erroneous
well it is confusing what's confusing is
why anybody would think that an app like
this to allow illegal immigrants to
literally reserve a time to come to the
border and then be ushered in without an
interview without follow-up without
tracking is stunning it's absolutely
stunning let me ask you in my very short
time remaining something else about
Chinese Nationals I've only got a minute
left that is false let me ask you about
about the the Chinese Nationals who we
all saw coming over the border busloads
of them and then being released in the
American Interior what's the what's the
percentage increase of Chinese Nationals
who cross the border this year Mr
secretary let's just focus on maybe the
Rio Grande Valley the number of the not
the number of Chinese Nationals
encountered on the southern border uh
has increased significantly do you know
how much over the past I don't have the
precise I do it's not it's 900 percent
just in the Rio Grande Valley sector are
any of any of these people who came in
this busty's Chinese Nationals members
of the Chinese Communist Party
um Senator if an individual presents a
national security or Public Safety
threat we detain them during the
pendants but that's not what I asked I
asked if they're members of the CCP
hearing dependency of their removal
proceedings are any of these individuals
members of the CCP I think there's about
70 who came on this bus if indeed they
are determined to be a national security
threat or a threat to Public Safety we
detain them pending their removal
proceedings were any of these
individuals detained or were they
released into
awareness of that particular group of
individuals
um and so you don't know if any of them
were members of the CCP or actually you
do know you just won't say I I don't
know from the photograph Senator but
surely you know about the folks who
you've read this report you're the
Secretary of Homeland Security you're
aware of these individuals were any of
the members of the Chinese Communist
party coming into this country Senator
you're providing me with a group of
individuals without names identities or
so you're not familiar with this
incident that was widely reported on at
the southern border don't you think it's
strange that we have busloads of Chinese
Nationals coming across our Southern
border I'm asking you from a hostile
country I'm asking you if they're
members of the Chinese Communist party
and you're you won't you don't know
apparently you won't say we are very
focused uh on all things with respect to
the people's Republicans but you don't
know any of the details I plead
exhaustion Mr secretary you have
exhausted me you have exhausted this
panel you have exhausted the patience of
the American people you should resign
Senator Welch
uh thank you very much welcome
just a couple of things first of all a
brief statement then uh I'd like to ask
you about some of these questions
including give you an opportunity
perhaps to elaborate on the question
that Senator Holly was asking uh but
first of all Mr chairman let me Express
the frustration I have
about this whole issue
we conflate everything into one thing
and never start talking specifically
about the elements that we have to
address we've got a drug problem with
fentanyl
that's separate from immigration but
some of it comes in on the border and
that's a serious conversation in my view
that deserves its own Focus
second we have a labor problem
we need more H1 h2a and h2b visas and I
believe that could be dealt with and
addressed separately to try to meet the
needs that many of our employers have
and also to get some more control and
management On the Border
third we've got these young people who
are not so young now many of whom have
served in the military but they were
brought over by their parents when they
were seven or eight or nine years old we
have one who's a graduate of UVM medical
school and he has an uncertain status
and the only country he's ever really
known is the United States and he's a
big contributor we should be dealing
with the dreamers separately
and then fourth we've got an incredible
challenge at the southern border and an
emerging challenge at the northern
border so whether you want to use the
term crisis or not it is a very serious
problem when two million people show up
at your door
that's a problem because we don't have
the capacity to accommodate that
and probably our toughest issue
now
some of these issues are because
Congress has failed to act I think
Senator Lee made some really good points
about parole but that's within our
jurisdiction to Define what that is and
if we do nothing how can we blame an
Administration
for trying to do something that makes
sense to try to get some control over
the border so this is on Congress
and uh you know Senator Cruz I I maybe I
would use the term uh uh crisis at the
border because two million people
showing up you know that's a really
serious problem
uh but it's not as though that it any
individual who has Mr mayorkas's job
whether in the Trump Administration the
bite Administration can control a lot of
what happens
and the thing that we're not
acknowledging here
is that if you have two million people
showing up because of various factors
that makes them so desperate that
they'll even come with their children
a war in Ukraine
a rogue Rebel group showing up to Syria
alone chopping off hands of 16 year old
kids who then apply for Refugee status
or failed States in Cuba in Venezuela in
Nicaragua and people being so desperate
they're willing to risk walking through
the Darien Gap
I mean secretary mayorkas can't handle
that and I mean you can't stop those
factors you have nothing to do with them
you've got to deal with the consequences
of them
and my view is that each one of these
elements that I've described has an
urgency of its own and requires focused
attention including some of these legal
questions that Senator Cruz you've
raised and Senator Lee is raised
that's just by way of background to
express my own frustration about what I
see as a failure of Congress to do its
part
now secretary mayorkas I want to give
you a chance to address the questions
that Senator Holly was Raising and just
take a minute to do that so thank you
Senator so let me let me explain uh the
program that we uh announced and have
been implementing since January 5th
because it's been tremendously
successful
we were encountering but quickly we were
encountering a significant number of
individuals from Cuba Haiti Nicaragua
and Venezuela and with respect to Cuba
Nicaragua and Venezuela Venezuela
specifically it's extremely difficult to
remove individuals from those countries
because of the status of our lack of
diplomatic relations we were seeing it
in one month up to 90 000 Encounters of
the individuals from those four
countries in between our ports of entry
in one month and what we did because we
do see tremendous tragedy at the hands
of the smuggling organizations is
develop a safe lawful and orderly way
for them to come to the United States
instead of placing their lives and their
life savings in the hands of the
Smugglers we have seen a 95 drop in the
number of individuals from those
countries encountered at our Southern
Border in between the ports of Entry
because people will take a lawful safe
and orderly path and not okay take an
irregular path thank the hands of
Smugglers thank you I want to go to
fentanyl Senator cornyn led a codel to
Mexico and it was tremendous and
constructive and I want to thank him for
that Senator Lee was on that
there was an interaction with the
president of Mexico led by Chris Murphy
and also uh by by Jerry Moran Senators
who confronted the president about the
precursor drugs that are coming into
Mexico from China and then used in the
manufacturing at fentanyl that comes up
to the United States
and they asked and received what I heard
was a very strong commitment on the part
of the president of Mexico
to address China we don't really have
that opportunity but to address China
about stopping those precursors
that's a level of cooperation that we
need more of would you agree uh yes yes
indeed and we've spoken as well uh with
our Mexican counterparts about the need
to interdict the precursor chemicals as
well as the manufacturing all right and
president uh Oberlin had a real
objection to all the guns that are
coming from the U.S into Mexico and then
ending up in the hands of cartels that
just commit unspeakable violence with
them are we doing all we can to
cooperate with the president to keep our
guns from going south yes we are senator
now you have authorities under Section
702 of fisa is that helpful at all to
you with respect to addressing the
fentanyl crisis it is extraordinarily
helpful we have over the years uh
stopped a terrorism uh terrorists from
arriving in the United States using our
702 Authority our intelligence
collection capabilities with respect to
foreign Nationals
what are the concrete steps we can take
to try to alleviate the pressure
on the southern border
that you would recommend that we pay
more attention to I would say there
there are a multiple number one first
and foremost we have to fix our broken
immigration system everyone agrees it is
broken uh number two uh we need to build
safe lawful and orderly Pathways so
people do not Place their lives in the
hands of Smugglers we have to cut the
smuggling organizations out and we have
to reduce irregular migration and build
lawful Pathways okay and three we have
to address the root causes what you
spoke of at the very outset why do
people leave their homes their countries
of origin to travel through multiple
countries to ultimately reach the United
States or elsewhere because we're seeing
enormous migration throughout the entire
my final minute let me ask you about the
northern border this is Vermont in New
York as well we're seeing a surge
between October 1 and December 31 2022
CPP apprehended 1146 migrants Crossing
into the U.S through the Swanton section
sector that's up in Northwest Vermont
during that same period in 2021 it was
only 136 migrants uh more are crossing
from the United States into Canada at
the northern border what are we doing
about the situation of migrants from the
U.S traveling to Canada and Canada to
the U.S so we're very focused on that
Senator as I mentioned earlier in my
testimony and what we did what we
announced just last week is a perfect
example of our Focus we
finished we promulgated the safe Third
Country agreement with Canada to bring
greater enforcement authority to both
our countries with respect to Encounters
in between the ports of Entry
okay uh thank you and just before I
yield back I would just say to all of my
colleagues you know we can have whoever
happens to be the secretary Homeland
Security and bring them in and beat them
up
or we can do our job
and my hope is we could do our job I
yield back
Madam chair
I called Senator cotton I'd just like to
offer by unanimous consent to admit two
documents into the record one is a news
article dated March 22nd and bearing the
caption by Administration scaling back
the tension of illegal immigrants
despite migrant surge the other is the
ice budget overview from FY 2024 showing
what the button Administration is doing
to scale back funding for bed space and
bedspace thanks without objection
Senator cotton secretary mayorkas the
uyghur people are a religious and ethnic
minority in Northwest China your
Administration and the last
Administration have both concluded that
the Chinese government is committing
genocide against his people do you agree
with that assessment yes I do and it's
why we are so vigorously in enforcing
the uyghur forced labor prevention act
well thank you for the
candid answer on that that's much better
than for instance The Tick Tock CEO
could give last week about the genocide
against his people part of congress's
reaction as you suggested was in 2021
passing a bill that I and many other
sponsors in fact I think it was a
majority of senators known as the uyghur
forced labor prevention act it passed
the Senate uh unanimously so I know that
you're familiar with it the law requires
Customs and Border Protection at DHS to
presume that materials sourced from that
Province are produced by forced labor
because of the widespread usage of
forced labor in the province among the
suppressed people it bars those products
from importation into the United States
and under that law every textile
manufacturer has to certify that their
imported materials aren't sourced from
xinjiang Province in China
it's come to my attention that a
veteran-owned company called Nine line
apparel which Prides itself on ethically
sourced products recently decided to
trust but verify their supplier
certifications that the cotton they were
using originated in Central America
rather than in China
so they had their supposedly clean
textile Imports professionally tested
turned out that slave produced fabric
from China was mixed in and passed off
as Central American cotton
nylon apparel did the right thing got
rid of all that material and they
reported it to Customs and Border
Protection
offering to give them all the evidence
they needed from their professional
testing facility but unfortunately CBP
decided not to follow up they directed
nine line apparel to submit a complaint
to a generic email box which was not
replied to
when nine line apparel CEO Then followed
up by calling CBP directly CBP told him
that enforcing this act this acts ban on
slave produced textiles and other fabric
is not one of their top priorities
Mr secretary is enforcing the federal
ban on slave produced products and
materials from China a top priority for
your department it most certainly is why
would CBP have told the CEO of nine line
apparel this is not a top priority I am
uh that is not um a reflection of our
prioritization of this work nor is it
consistent with our prioritization of
this work and I must say that the ACT is
an incredibly important statute that
Congress passed and I appreciate your
leadership in achieving it it is
something that we enforce very very
vigorously and need to do so and I
should say that the ACT provides that it
is it pertains to materials produced in
whole or in part
with forced labor and I cite that
because that is very important language
because we do not countenance at all the
use of forced labor by the PRC and we
cannot allow materials into the United
States that are in violation of the
statute okay thank you for that answer
Mr secretary I think it's important that
we heard that here in public for
everyone in CBP to hear that their
secretary believes that the enforcement
of the uyghur forced labor prevention
Act is a top priority correct oh yes and
let me assure you that the Personnel of
CBP
um are in perfect lockstep okay with me
I know that sometimes in bureaucracies
messages don't always get transmitted as
clearly As Leaders might like so I'm
glad that we have you saying that
clearly today I would also like uh to be
able to follow up with you and your team
in the next couple weeks about this
specific case of nine line apparel and
see what might have happened in that
matter I look forward to doing so second
um I want to turn to tick tock
we've had a lot of talk about fentanyl
today rightly so given the Surge and
drug deaths in this country Tick Tock
has sometimes been referred to as
digital Fentanyl you may have seen last
week that the CEO of tick tock testified
and he tried to pass off this Chinese
Communist spying app uh as safe because
it had a quote U.S based team
who oversees the massive amounts of
Americans data that Tick Tock vacuums up
so I want to talk about those U.S based
employees
last year your department approved more
than 700 applications for foreign
Nationals to work at Tick Tock and bite
dances offices in California do you
happen to recall how many of those 700
or Chinese Nationals
let me let me assure you uh Senator that
we are very focused on the threat that
Tick Tock presents and we are very very
focused on the threat that the PRC so
I'll come I'll come to that General
threat in a moment I'm December do you
recall how many of those 700 foreign
Nationals that were approved to work at
Tick Tock and bike dances California
offices were Chinese Nationals Senator I
would be very pleased to look into that
there's 445.
um it doesn't sound like a U.S based
team to me despite whatever
Xiao Chu the CEO of tick tock said last
week if they're predominantly Chinese
Nationals you think employees coming to
work at bike dance and Tick Tock in the
United States uh might be tied to the
Chinese Communist party or the people's
Liberation Army Senator that is indeed a
concern of ours and we are working to
ensure that the Visa screening process
is as robust and Vigilant as it needs to
be but let me let me share also uh that
of course The Tick Tock uh transaction
is something that is under a review and
is the subject of litigation we are very
very focused on
um the Peril that Tick Tock presents I I
understand I I think Tick Tock should
have been banned a long time ago I would
point out that last week as the
administration floated this plan
so-called project Texas which I think is
deeply misguided and the sale of tick
tock China's government said they would
never allow that to happen which
contradicts everything Tick Tock has
ever said about not being beholden to
the Chinese government but I want to
come back to your department the cyber
security and infrastructure Security
Agency or sisa reports to you they call
themselves America's cyber Defense
Agency I looked on their website
recently
um as far as I can tell though sisa has
never issued a warning about Tick Tock
other than to recommend people update
The Tick Tock app to fix
software bugs I gotta say I'm less
concerned about bugs and Tick Tock than
I am about features in Tick Tock and the
features are Tick Tock is it's designed
to vacuum up every bit of data on an
American's phone not just their videos
from the app itself but their contacts
their emails their text messages or
photos perhaps even activate their
microphones and their cameras remotely
so has sisa ever issued a warning to the
American people about Tick Tock other
than updating the software to avoid bugs
Senator cisa's focus is indeed on cyber
security we are a member of the
committee of for foreign investments in
the United States sypheus of which you
are very familiar and we and across the
administration are focused on The Tick
Tock uh challenge more broadly well I I
would encourage you and cisa to take a
more uh or to take a closer look at this
and make it more prominent on the
website I think many Americans still
don't understand why so many of their
elected officials are so hostile to tick
tock even that hearing last week when
Democrats and Republicans alike
excoriated the disgraceful performance
of xiaochu this Tick Tock CEO they're
still wondering why uh their elected
officials are so worried about their
privacy and their security let's turn to
Mr Chu do you know what nationality
xiaochu is I do not Senator it's hard to
find out on the internet what he is he's
often referred to as a Singaporean he
spent a lot of time in America though if
you look at his resume I assume that
he's not an American citizen
because if he was I'm pretty sure Tick
Tock would refer to him as our American
CEO as they did his short-term
predecessor Senator um just a number of
months ago I was in Singapore
um and to uh to address in the
indo-pacific region uh the threat that
the PRC presents when uh countries
accept their loans there's no free lunch
as I articulated in my remarks and how
precarious it is to allow the PRC to
actually build and own the
infrastructure upon which many of these
countries rely well I I appreciate that
I just want I have a few concluding
Thoughts with Mr Chu who seems to me
like it
Communist Party stooge and the agent of
communist influence in America you know
he wouldn't admit what you admitted very
quickly and highlighted the importance
of that China's committing a genocide
against its own people in fact I think
he was asked once if Tick Tock spies on
Americans and his answer was that well
he wouldn't use the word spying is
exactly the right word so
the immigration nationality act uh makes
any alien deportable if they quote
engage in any activity to violate any
law of the United States relating to
espionage or sabotage or a few other
things
seems to me that Mr Chu is a foreign
National in the United States
representing an
essentially an arm or an agency of the
Chinese Communist party as they
acknowledged last week he shouldn't be
allowed to stay in the United States he
certainly shouldn't be invited back in I
don't think we need agents of Chinese
Communist influence in our country
especially coming to spread their lives
in the United States Congress see my
time is expired I look forward to
following up with you on the forced
Labor Act matter and thank you for
clarifying that for all of your CBP
officers around the country thank you
senator
I call on myself for 10 minutes welcome
Mr secretary
um I would ask for unanimous consent to
enter into the record an opinion piece
by two Governors Eric Holcomb Republican
governor of Indiana Spencer Cox
Republican governor of Utah and it is an
opinion piece for the Washington Post
entitled to solve our national
immigration crisis let's State sponsor
immigrants they call upon Congress to
end the two decade-long impasse
regarding comprehensive immigration
reform and they note that we are a
nation of immigrants and I know that Mr
secretary you are a political Refugee
and
since you came to our country seeking a
better life your parents and you which
is why most immigrants come to this
country you have spent decades as a
federal prosecutor and a public servant
in the United States and I thank you for
that and of course as as the only
immigrant serving in the U.S Senate
right now I certainly understand the
desire to come to a parental desire to
come to this country to create a better
life for themselves and their children
certainly the case for me and it informs
what I do and why I do it
the Trump Administration completed
472 executive actions related to
immigration policy many of which were
punitive and cruel in fact there were
people who said that cruelty was the
intent of these policies and who can
forget the pictures of children who
literally were ripped from the arms of
their parents crying for their parents
in our detention facilities and only
when a court ordered reunification did
the Trump Administration then try to
reunify these children and it was
difficult because the the administration
had absolutely no desire or goal to
reunify these children with their
parents so they didn't keep track
of of the children and their parents so
these were inhumane policies and I heard
today that maybe if we reverted to those
policies
that we would be solving our immigration
problems
Mr secretary would reverting to
cruel and inhumane policies like child
separation or an asylum band be the
answer
Senator I appreciate your remarks about
why people come to this country for a
better life I appreciate your mention of
my personal journey to this United
States my parents brought my sister and
me here to live in a democracy of the
Communist Regime took everything away
that my father had and it is why I have
served for approximately 22 years in
federal service on behalf of the United
States government to give back to this
country
Senator there's a core principle of our
Administration we are a nation of laws
and we are a nation of immigrants
and how we enforce our laws and the
policies that we promulgate the policies
that we issue must reflect our values
and you cite one of the most heinous
policies of the prior Administration uh
family separation to remove young
children out of the clutches of their
parents in an effort to deter other
individuals from coming to the United
States and assert an asylum claim I'm
very proud to lead the family
reunification task force that the
president ordered by way of executive
action and we have reunited more than
600 of those children with their parents
here in the United States
and our work is not done
and certainly going back to those
policies are not the answer in fact let
me turn to a program that
I think is better
position to address some of the issues
relating to immigration
in 2016 DHS implemented A detention
alternative the family case management
program initially for five years the
Trump DHS shut it down after only one
and a half years
but the data showed that this more
Humane program was almost also more cost
effective than detention and it has an
amazing compliance rate with more than
99 appearance rates at check check-ins
and Court hearings I understand that DHS
has a has relaunched a program to
provide Case Management Services to some
immigrants given the success of the
family case management program do you
expect to see similar results with the
new program
yes yes I do Senator and in fact we've
we've done more than that just recently
I asked the homeland security advisory
Council on outside body to take a look
at our alternatives to detention
programs including the case management
uh pilot to which you refer and to
provide recommendations about what are
the most Humane as well as effective
programs to ensure that people can
comply with their legal obligations in a
very very complex immigration system
that everyone agrees is fundamentally
broken and in dire need of repair and
that's been the case for decades
I think I'm really glad that you
continue to emphasize that the Humane
policies that we should be following
rather than policies where cruelty seem
to be the object of the policy certainly
they the tearing of children from the
arms of their parents can be cannot be
characterized as anything but cruel I
mentioned the op-ed that these the two
Governors Republican Governors wrote and
they are facing literally over a hundred
thousand worker shortages in both of
their states and of
we are facing a severe work of shortage
in our country and I want to quote the
Chamber of Commerce maybe the first time
that I would quote Chamber of Commerce
and they said quote the vast
shortcomings of our legal immigration
system are a key contributing factor as
to why companies are struggling to hire
and retain the talent they need to
succeed in an increasingly competitive
Global Marketplace end quote
Mr secretary is the workers shortage
especially in cyber security for example
a security threat and whose job is it to
fix our legal immigration system so
Senator it is an economic security
threat uh the
um
uh the shortage of workers we have
employers who are striving to hire to
find people who could fill jobs to
contribute to our country's economic
Prosperity regrettably regrettably our
legal immigration system is not designed
to meet that need of employers here in
the United States despite the fact
despite the fact that individuals from
other countries want to come here to
work even seasonally even temporarily
earn the money that they can bring back
to their home countries and support
their families there it is precisely why
in the h2b program the seasonal
non-agricultural worker program we
allocated thousands of h2b visas for the
Central American countries of Guatemala
Honduras and El Salvador so that those
individuals in desperate need of a
better life do not have to place their
lives in the hands of Smugglers take the
perilous journey to our Southern border
and arrive in between the southern in
between the ports of Entry if indeed
they make it safely but instead to
fulfill the need for labor here in the
United States we can screen and vet
these individuals in their home
countries and they can travel safely to
the United States by air gain lawful
employment contribute to our economy
return to their home countries with the
earnings that they've made and address
fundamentally the root causes of why
people travel irregularly in the first
place
we just cannot seem to fix a system that
everyone agrees is broken
you and I uh as immigrants we know why
our families brought us to this country
it is to give us a better life I came
here with nothing and a single parent
and I I just wish that my colleagues who
talk about their own families and their
their their grandparents their parents
being immigrants they seem to have
forgotten the struggles that they
experienced to make a better life for
them and here we all are you know there
was a time not too long ago in 2013 when
we managed to get comprehensive
immigration reform done it didn't solve
all of the crises that we faced but it
was at least a start and it was actually
bipartisan some of my colleagues sitting
here were very involved in doing that
and I'm thinking why does the Chamber of
Commerce have to come forward and
practically beg us to to pay attention
to the massive work of shortage in our
country why do two Republican Governors
don't want to wait around any longer for
congress whose responsibility I'm
answering my own question now whose
responsibility it is to do comprehensive
immigration they form these two
Governors Republican Governors saying we
can't wait for you guys we would like to
be able to bring immigrants to our state
so that there they can have the kind of
strong economy that they seek for their
states so my goodness why can't we get
it done we did it before my time is up
thank you Mr chairman I liked your
testimony so much I didn't want to
interrupt you but thank you senator
hirono
Senator Kennedy
thank you Mr chairman welcome Mr
secretary thank you Senator Mr secretary
do you agree with the president that we
should ban the private ownership
of assault weapons in America
Senator I do
what is an assault weapon it is for
example in an AK-47
uh can you give me a definition other
than just pointing to a specific weapon
would there be other weapons besides an
AK-47 you would ban uh they're uh very
well are and I remember when I was a
federal prosecutor in the central
district of California from September
25th 1989 to I believe it was April
2001. and I thank you for your service
the vast majority of law enforcement
officers uh Leaders with whom I worked
uh uh were greatly in support of the
assault weapons so why we get so
frustrated with you because you won't
give straight answers I think I just did
no you didn't
no you didn't do you have a death a
definition of an assault weapon
I am confident there is a technical
definition of what is an assault weapon
uh and it was assuredly used uh in the
context of the statute that previously
existed Banning assault weapons
um Mr Mr secretary our Southern border
is not secure is it Senator
um I have spoken about this I believe
I've addressed this earlier in the
hearing why don't you address it again
of course let me let me share with you
um a few things number one when I speak
of the security of the Border I'm
speaking of maximizing the resources we
have to deliver the most effective
results so let me assure you we are
secure because we're trying to secure it
are we succeeding uh Senator we are so
focused on the security of our Southern
border we are doing so much
The Surge of Personality you're not
succeeding oh Senator let me share with
you that the challenge of migration that
we are experiencing at our Southern
border is not exclusive to the United
States it is something that is gripping
the entire Heaven my job is to worry
about the United States as is mine as is
mine and here's my question let me try
to rephrase it
and I really do wish I understand the
position you're in but you really should
try to do a better job of answering the
questions
um
under the bad Administration we have the
most encounters
we have had the most encounters with
people attempting to come into our
country illegally
in the history of ever
under the Biden Administration we have
had the most people entering our country
illegally
in the history of ever
under the Biden Administration we have
had the most uh gotaways
at our Southern Border in the history of
ever
under the Biden Administration we have
had the most number of people entering
our country under a claim of asylum
having that claim turned down and still
not being deported in the history of
ever
and under the Biden Administration we've
had the most fentanyl coming into our
country in this history of ever how can
you possibly say the southern border is
secure do you understand your answer
that you're trying but I'm not asking
about your efforts I'm asking about the
results well let's talk about the
results then Senator do you know that
last year we expelled and removed
approximately 1.4 million people from
the southern border I believe that's the
most ever
do you realize uh that we are focused on
enforcing our laws to achieve the
security of the Southern border I know
your focus Mr chairman butcher our Mr
secretary but you're not succeeding uh
Senator when you come testify to us you
talk about
how you're trying really hard
and and I don't have any way to disprove
that I I accept that statement in good
faith
but the numbers below that if I can
Senator let me give you an example of a
solution that we have delivered that um
for some reason is being contested
because it's it's caused a 95 in 30
seconds okay it's caused the 95. don't
filibuster me it's closed on that all
day I'm just trying to I'm just trying
to communicate it has it has led to a
approximately 95 drop in the number of
Encounters in between the ports of Entry
at our Southern border of Cubans
Haitians nicaraguans and Venezuelans on
January 5th and why would that be
opposed when it is delivering precisely
the result that you seek did you just
parachute in from another's Planet Mr
secretary because you're the only person
in the Milky Way
who believes that we're not having
massive massive illegal immigration into
America
Senator you're
um you're putting words into my mouth
I'm expertly describing the situation
there is no question there is no
question that we have a very serious
challenge at our Southern border okay it
is a challenge we can agree on that let
me ask you another question
um
why don't you just declare a new policy
that other than children
if you presented the southern border you
claim Refugee status
you claim political Asylum
and you haven't claimed the refugee
status and political Asylum at the first
safe country then you can't come in
Senator so first of all when one
presents at the border it's an asylum
claim why don't you do that why don't
you you know adequately declare that it
a safe Third Country policy it would
work
you can't come into America if you're
coming from Venezuela and you come
through Mexico if you didn't claim
Asylum Mexico you can't come here you
have to leave why don't you just do that
well um Senator uh let me give you an
example with respect to Mexico a safe
Third Country agreement let's
hypothetically you don't have to have an
agreement with Mexico yes you do no you
don't I believe you do no you don't I'll
have the countries don't do it just
adopt a policy that says except for
children because you don't want to send
children back by themselves just adopt a
new policy that if if you if you didn't
seek asylum in the first safe Third
Country you can't come in Period Senator
are you aware of the notice of proposed
rulemaking that we issued the comment
period of which closed yesterday you've
had two years to adopt a policy like I
just described why haven't you done it
so Senator what we have done is but why
have you done haven't you done that we
have surged enforcement resources we
have just adopted please if you would Mr
secretary answer my question it is my
understanding why haven't you and why
haven't you adopted unilaterally a safe
Third Country policy that would stop
except for children all the folks from
the northern triangle countries all the
folks from Venezuela all the folks from
Cuba all the folks in the Middle East
from coming into our country
why haven't you done that a senator is
my understanding that those are two
things it is my understanding that those
agreements do require uh you don't have
to have an agreement with anybody it can
be a policy established by the
Department of Homeland and security uh
Senator uh I'd have to review the you
haven't reviewed that you haven't
considered that possibility let me let
me finish if I may sure I would have to
review the under uh the legal
underpinnings of yours you better get
reviews on it also the audience this is
the first time that's occurred I also do
not think that that is sound policy you
don't think that's that this is the
first time that's occurred to you I also
do not think that that is sound policy
that we should shut down our entire
Asylum system I didn't say shut down the
entire Asylum system I I said safe Third
Country all you have to do Mr secretary
if you're really serious in this
beginning frankly to appear that you're
not is adopt diplomacy that says
we're not we're not seeking anyone's
agreement we don't have to
if you're coming from another country
and you come through let's say Mexico
and you say you're you're you're seeking
Asylum you have to seek it in Mexico or
the other first safe third country or
you can't come in period done end of
story
why don't you do that uh Senator
um I don't think that we have the
unilateral Authority sure you do number
two try sneaking into China as I've
mentioned I do not think that is sound
policy why because you are basically
shutting down our Asylum system no
you're not you're saying we respect we
honor your right to seek political
Asylum but but you're cherry picking do
it in Mexico first
but Ryan said you've done that I I've I
I think I've addressed that issue
Senator you don't want to do it Mr
secretary that's what it's beginning to
look like because you think our borders
ought to be open and it would be more
intellectually honest if you just say
that that is false I don't agree with
you you have to watch up here what
people do not what they say and
everything else is just cottage cheese
uh Senator I don't think I don't think
that 1.4 million people who were
expelled or removed last year would
consider the Border open Mr chairman
you've had our Mr secretary you've had
billions a Millions coming into the
country illegally the most of the
history of ever under your watch
and everybody knows that apparently
except you either that or you're not
being forthcoming we've also had the
largest number of individuals expelled
or removed from the southern border and
if one takes a look at the apprehension
uh and encounter uh numbers
uh and then the removal uh numbers one
would have a different uh view if you do
the safe Third Country policy that'll
solve half of your problem right there
and you're not denying anybody Asylum
thank you Senator Kennedy senator isoff
thank you Mr chairman
uh welcome secretary mayorkas
I'd like to discuss with you
the h2a Visa program
uh whereby as you know uh
agricultural workers
can pursue a Visa legally to work in the
United States
to support the production of food in our
country
and this is a program of course vets
extensively utilized by our agricultural
sector
important for our food security
but last year a federal investigation
called operation blooming onion
uncovered that some Farm Workers
who were in the country
through the h2a Visa program legally to
work
had been subjected to Human Rights
abuses and labor conditions
so severe and inhumane that the
Department of Justice deemed them to
constitute modern-day slavery
so I sent you a letter on March 1st 2022
to ask you to reform
the administration of this program to
ensure that Farm Workers
legally with an h2a Visa entering the
United States would not be subjected
to such appalling and inhumane treatment
and you responded and I appreciate your
response just a couple of months later
and inform me that you would in fact
undertake such reform and that you'd
begun a rule-making process to do so
so I'd like to ask you for an update
please on that rulemaking process and on
the Department's efforts to ensure that
workers in the United States through the
h2a Visa program are not subjected to
these crimes and this catastrophic
treatment
Senator uh thank you very much so two
things number one the rule making is
underway I believe and number two and I
can provide you with a more specific
update
after this hearing but critically
or I should say end critically
we have revised our worksite enforcement
strategy for precisely the reason that
you identify precisely because of what
we observed in operation blooming onion
and tragically in other circumstances as
well art enforcement resources in the
worksite environment are focused on
investigating and Prosecuting employers
who exploit the vulnerability of the
migrant Workforce by paying them
substandard wages by keeping them in
substandard working conditions not only
exploiting the vulnerable workers
themselves but also creating an unfair
advantage in the marketplace because
through those conditions through the
imposition of those conditions they
charge Less Price lower prices and
create an unfair competitive Advantage
so it is unscrupulous employers upon
whom we are bringing to Bear our
worksite enforcement authorities will
you please provide my office with an
update will your staff please provide my
office with an update by the end of this
week on the expected date for completion
of
this initial rule making process yes and
I should say that the worksite
enforcement strategy that we announced
several months ago is already underway
it does not require rulemaking it is a
matter of using our enforcement
authorities and resources most
effectively and that is how we are doing
so understood
continuing the discussion about the h2a
program
and considering in particular
the small and medium-sized farmers and
Growers who utilize it
recognizing that
the various elements within DHS have
significant resource constraints and a
lot of work to do including ensuring the
fair and Humane treatment of workers
under this program
DHS has proposed dramatically increasing
the application fees charged by USCIS
for a variety of Visa programs
including for h2a and h2b petitions
whereby employers could see increases of
up to 250 percent in a single year and
of course we're in an environment where
farmers are facing High fuel prices High
fertilizer prices and where Americans
are facing
High grocery prices
so my question for you is in developing
this proposed Rule and the increase in
fees for USCIS for h2a and h2b programs
have you consulted the Department of
Agriculture and is there some
accommodation that can be made to ensure
that there are not crippling fees
imposed upon small and medium-sized
farmers who are having a tough time
right now so Senator if I may um so the
the fee rule to which you
um refer is to an effort to try to get
U.S citizenship and Immigration Services
back on stable Financial footing a fee
rule the adjustment of costs for
immigration benefits is supposed to be
revised every two years a fee rule has
not issued for more than six years so
that agency was decimated in the prior
Administration and the reason for the
proposed significant increases in
certain costs for certain benefits is by
reason of that fact and the need to
actually Infuse much needed funding for
that agency it is not a rule that we
promulgate unilaterally but rather it is
in the proposed rule-making stage we are
receiving comments in response to it and
no final decisions have been made good
well I want to urge you to consider the
economic circumstances of those small
and medium-sized farmers in particular
with such a sudden increase in the fees
they rely upon the fees for the Visa
services that they rely upon let me ask
you about DHS detention practices as you
know I led an investigation in the
permanent subcommittee of Investigations
last year whose findings were deeply
disturbing indeed horrifying this
bipartisan investigation I led with
Senator Johnson of Wisconsin found that
female detainees and DHS custody
detention in Georgia were subjected by a
DHS contracted doctor to excessive
invasive and often unnecessary
gynecological surgical procedures
including in some cases without out
informed consent and in November of last
year during a Homeland Security
Committee hearing you committed me to
review the findings of that
investigation we made a number of
recommendations in our report
accompanying that investigation
Expediting and improving vetting of
off-site medical providers
and dramatically strengthening the
procedures by which you ensure that DHS
detainees have the opportunity to
consent or not to Medical Services what
steps have you taken since that
investigation so uh Senator thank you
very much for the report that you and
Senator Johnson LED I did indeed review
that report as I think you know we
closed the facility that was the subject
of that investigation I did direct that
the recommendations be reviewed and
implemented to the fullest extent
possible and I'd be very pleased to get
you an updated report of the status of
that implementation
well I think that's that's urgent and I
I want to get that information as soon
as possible we're talking about
women convicted of no crime
in the custody of the U.S government
being subjected to gynecological
surgical procedures that were not
medically indicated often without
informed consent it's one of them and I
do want to State for the record that
that
this appalling activity occurred prior
to your tenure so there's no mistaking
for the public tuning you right now but
it is completely unacceptable that
practices May persist that leave women
in detention at risk of this treatment
and I I'm sure you agree with me Mr
secretary I want an update on what
you're doing to address it and finally I
want to talk to you about your Office of
Intelligence and Analysis yes and we are
addressing that with do urgency because
of precisely how appalling that conduct
was and what was going on in that
facility we closed that facility I know
you didn't I want to make sure that
there are practices being implemented
across DHS detention facilities to
ensure that can never ever happen again
so I look forward to that update I want
to ask you about your Intelligence and
Analysis office
uh there has been recent reporting about
problems at
the DHS Office of Intelligence and
Analysis
I don't think that the Congress has
sufficient visibility into its
activities
among the conduct alleged in this public
reporting
with respect to domestic intelligence
gathering by the Office of Intelligence
analysis
interviews with individuals in detention
centers local jails and federal prisons
without counsel present
that was one of the allegations made in
public reporting
this is deeply troubling and I don't
think that there is uh very intense
Congressional oversight of this office
is there a problem what are you doing to
address and identify the problem and
what does the Congress need to know so
senator of the Office of Intelligence
and Analysis is led by a phenomenal uh
public servant in in Ken Weinstein he's
the under secretary he has a tremendous
experience uh he was the homeland
security advisor to former President
Bush when you speak of the interviews of
individuals in custody who are in the
impending legal proceedings he suspended
that practice it was a practice that was
implemented first in the prior
Administration he suspended that
practice and he is really doing a
phenomenal job in ensuring that the
practices of Ina the Office of
Intelligence and Analysis adhere
to our laws as well as to our
fundamental principles of protecting the
Civil Rights and civil liberties as well
as the Privacy for their interviews of
U.S persons were there interviews of U.S
persons in federal prisons or local uh
local or state jails without Council
present by Ina Personnel
um I I believe that there were and that
was not necessarily always
um uh improper but the practice was
suspended because of concerns with
respect to it but I must say uh Senator
that the Personnel of the Office of
Intelligence and Analysis are incredibly
dedicated and Incredibly principled in
the execution of their responsibilities
thank you Mr secretary thank you Senator
rossoff Senator Blackburn thank you Mr
chairman before I begin my questions
today I do want to express my heartbreak
at what happened yesterday in Nashville
at Covenant School in Covenant
Presbyterian church and my family and I
are grieving along with the rest of the
community and I thank you Mr secretary
for your call yesterday your kind
remarks today and violence against
children is just one of the most heinous
crimes and the families they are at
covenant press and Covenant School I I
just grieve for what they're going
through we have to work to protect
children at school and that means
increasing security and I have and I
have had legislation that would allow
for training and hiring of veterans in
former law enforcement officials to
serve as school safety officers and to
help protect our school it is time for
us to pass that and to help keep our
children safe
um I'd like to turn to the questions
that are in front of us today Mr
secretary thank you for your patience
today
I want to go to this issue of human
smuggling and under this Administration
the human smuggling business has gone
from being a 500 million dollar a year
business to a 13 billion dollar a year
industry and we heard from secretary
Becerra last week at our Senate finance
committee and we've got 85 000
unaccompanied Alien Children migrant
children who have been released in the
U.S
the HHS has lost track of these
unaccompanied children so my question to
you is this how many of these children
are being trafficked how many of these
children are being put into the sex
trade what are you doing to try to find
these children and
when you look at what is happening to
women and children do you all understand
that it is the policies of this
Administration what you're doing on the
border that is causing 85 000 children
to be lost
can't find them
and not knowing if they're being
trafficked to put in gangs put in the
sex trade so what are you all doing to
find these children and do you
understand that it is the policies that
is causing this Senator let me um let me
share with you what we are doing
to address the scourge
of human smuggling and human trafficking
and let me say with respect to the
unaccompanied children and this will
Echo what I shared with Senator ossoff
just a moment ago with respect to
unaccompanied children when we receive
them
at the border it is our legal obligation
to release them to the care of the
Department of Health and Human Services
within that's right and now they cannot
find them within 70 85 000. and so what
we do is we release is that an
acceptable number oh absolutely not
right so what so let me let me share
with you so we release them one of the
reasons one of the reasons why we are
devoting our work site enforcement uh
resources
and energies on unscrupulous employers
is precisely for the reason that you
identify we must hold accountable
employers who engage in a child I
appreciate that let's look at it with
respect to the Border yeah and let's
look at let's look at it this way two
efforts we have underway one is we are
taking it to the smugglers in an
unprecedented they haven't gotten that
message oh yes oh yes they have I I beg
to differ because the situation it is
now a 13 billion dollar a year business
when you go to that border as I have
done and when you talk to women that
have been trafficked and have gotten
themselves out and have been raped
repeatedly there is a sexual assault
epidemic going on on that border and it
is because of the policies of this
Administration Senator and it is so
Senator it is because of the heinous
exploitation of the smuggling
organization and what is it
incentivizing that that do not that's
right that's exactly right and you and I
agree on that they do not care about
human life they see people as a product
and a way to make a buck because they
are billion dollar businesses they have
and let me turn to the fentanyl epidemic
because we've all talked about this and
I'm hearing from some of my sheriffs now
that from well from a Border Town
Sheriff
that fentanyl appeal now is down to
about five cents because they've teamed
up with the Chinese scientists they're
making these in the labs with the
cartels and I I think that you've talked
a little bit about the fentanyl today
but you really don't have an estimate of
how much is truly coming over that
border and we know that you're saying
that they are catching about 95 of that
but what I have heard is what you're
giving us is the CBP numbers you're not
giving us the numbers that are coming
from air and Marine operations you're
not including the Coast Guard you're not
including the DEA and you're not
including what is found by state and
local law enforcement so why won't you
look at the holistic number of what
everybody is finding oh a senator
the the scourge
of fentanyl is something that we do not
in any way underestimate let me if I may
share with you as I mentioned earlier I
served as a federal prosecutor for 12
years yes I prosecuted you're not
answering my question and I've only got
three minutes left if I can why are you
not just why do you not include what
everybody is fine state and local law
enforcement the DEA the Marine we do
Senator the question that was posed to
me was with respect to the southern
border and how fentanyl is trafficked
into the United States
but if you will vast majority of it is
brought in through the ports of Entry no
sir I beg to differ with that when you
talk to border patrol and you talk to
local sheriffs I would like to get from
you in writing a total number of what
you are finding not only from CBP but
also from the air and Marine operations
the Coast Guard the DEA and state and
local law enforcement let me move on
about the gotaways because we've had
over 1.2 million migrants that have
evaded authorities and have come into
the country illegally and it is of
concern to me when I hear you all try to
make illegal legal there's an app for
this and allowing people to continue to
come in
illegally now ice arrested 220 illegal
immigrants in nine days that had
criminal convictions of rape and murder
now it doesn't take rocket science to go
figure out that in those 1.2 million
that are unknown gotaways are known got
aways that number
that have disappeared in our country
that you've got murderers and criminals
and rapists that are in that number
That Got Away so how many of those have
made it into Tennessee how many are in
our communities how many are in our
streets are you all tracking these or
have you lost them like the 85 000
children Senator I would say I would say
two things number one we are intensely
focused on securing uh the Border as I
have testified earlier okay one and
number two I think it's very important
not to paint with a broad brush
individuals who come to the United
States well I think it's important to
note what border patrol is telling us if
you're intent on securing the Border
then you spend 50 million dollars a year
to caretake the the items components
from the border wall project that was in
the previous administration the border
wall by the way the border patrol has
been asking for a physical barrier for
decades I think about 30 years in total
so instead of wasting that money to do
nothing with the construction material
why don't you use those remaining
materials and that 50 million dollars
and fill in the gaps in this wall so
that the border patrol has a physical
barrier that they need Senator I've
approved the vast majority of the
projects to close the gaps and complete
the gates
with respect to the funding that we
received
Mr chairman I have one other question on
Chinese Nationals that I will submit for
a written answer thank you
thank you Senator Blackburn Senator
Tillis
good afternoon secretary mayarkas how's
your day going good afternoon Senator I
am I think I'm going to be the last one
to speak I want to start just by
thanking Senator rossop I've been
working with him on the HDA issues I
think that it's a struggle every year
with just the execution of that program
and uh I am a bit concerned I'm not
going to ask you to respond a big
concern with casting the users of the
h2a program uh I don't think you meant
it but I could have inferred that
they're all Bad actors speaking for
North Carolina I think housing workplace
safety compensation
is competitive and done appropriately so
I hope as you go about any kind of
changes there we don't paint all of the
players in agriculture with the same
broad brush oh absolutely I think it's
critically important because we could
have some unintended consequences that
are hurting farmers and we need to
recognize that tomatoes grow anywhere
blackberries grow anywhere and if we
don't get the wage rate right they won't
grow in the United States so we've got
to be very very surgical in our approach
we're about to become a net importer of
food in this country for the first time
in its history and I believe a part of
it is the unfriendly environment that
has been a bipartisan
multi-administration failure I think in
terms of getting it right but I'll do
questions for the record I'd like to
meet with you by the way you did well at
them at the Munich security conference I
think I watched you on a panel thank you
Senator I must say because it's I really
want to make sure if we do have time
allowing I want to get to it okay a few
more I think we will with the 10-minute
round but um I I did want to correct for
the record I think you asked a question
or answered a question uh to Senator Lee
about you didn't have any intent to
reduce the tension but the acting
director testified for House
Appropriations Homeland Security and
said that ice wanted to reduce bed space
from 36 to 25 can you reconcile that for
me from 36 000 to 25 000. yes I can I
think um that is addressing the fiscal
year 2024 uh president's budget and what
we've done is we've presented a baseline
uh in the budget but we've also
um uh sought an appropriation for a 4.7
billion dollar Southern border
contingency fund because of the dynamism
of the border and and the situation
there the surgeon and so yes
because I don't want to have uh
clarification for Senator release time
I'm cutting them on too much but uh just
for the basis of clarification I'd like
to know based on the budget uh what Isis
position us now with what I think is
roughly 36 000 do you and do you expect
to see that go down based on the
administration's priorities now I want
to talk I want to get uh Sanctuary
cities and a few other things um
4.9 million encounters with illegal
immigrants we know that some of those
are double counted because they're
multiple Crossings 1.2 million gotaways
these are folks who came here
did not present themselves did not want
to be processed many of them they wanted
to get into this country and Escape
apprehension I've been to the Border
several times most of the people come
across the border they Follow the arrow
from the Rio Grande River they go to a
processing facility they go through a
process that's overwhelmed but 1.2
million gotaways based on my numbers if
they're different you could submit it to
for a question for the record over the
past couple of years
six hundred thousand illegal immigrants
released into the country without
monitoring again we won't debate back
and forth I'd just like to say if that's
roughly the number that you all were
working with 285 thousand
released into the country with some sort
of electronic monitoring about 27 000 in
detention and 890 deaths in 2022. of
people trying to cross the border I saw
one of them being taken out of the
out of the Rio Grande river in one of my
last visits over the past year and a
half uh Mr chair I'd like to submit for
the record article that was published in
the Wall Street Journal it's titled it's
like a graveyard record number of
migrants are dying
at the U.S border without objection
um
we have a problem at the border and I
think you may acknowledge some of that
but you fall short of calling it a
crisis these numbers look to me like a
crisis without any viable strategy
moving forward
I believe that the cartels it's been
reported that the cartels are making as
much as 800 million dollars a year in
their human trafficking operation with
the tolls that they uh that they charge
people some are paid before they cross
the Rio Grande River others are paid
once they get here and they entered into
modern day indentured servitude paying
back the cartels for the toll over here
and we're seeing estimates ranging
anywhere from five thousand to fifty
thousand dollars
depending upon your country of origin
if I have time I'll get back to that
Sanctuary cities ice do you consider ice
a law enforcement agency yes I do do you
consider a lack of cooperation among law
enforcement agencies as being a
potentially
hazardous step to take yes I do do you
believe that Sanctuary cities is a case
example of where local law enforcement
refuses to cooperate with ice Senator
the term Sanctuary City means different
things in different places I'm just
referring to legislation and policies
that were passed in my state where they
used it but I do not I do not agree when
they cut it out it's like uh I think a
week or so ago where we had three
illegal immigrants from Romania they
were arrested and charged with obtaining
property under false premises and one
was charged with sexual battery of a
minor thankfully in this jurisdiction
they did detain them ice was allowed to
do their job I've got over 3 million
people
state of 10 million
three million people living in sanctuary
jurisdictions which is why I proposed
and we'll propose again a violence for
victims of sanctuary cities and it's
fairly simple it says that if a local
government entity has a sanctuary policy
call it whatever you want to
um
uh refusing to cooperate with ice policy
we'll call it that because that's
fundamentally what they're doing I feel
like they should be unaccountable if
their actions produce harm if someone
gets murdered like somebody did in the
Charlotte area with somebody who was
could have been transferred to ice are
countless examples across the country I
simply want a private right of action
for the agreed party are there survivors
in the event of death to be able to Sue
that governmental entity now it's fairly
straightforward to be if the policies
are fair if they're safe then they've
got nothing to worry about
and then if they declare immunity then
they'll be denied uh federal funds for
law enforcement so make a decision but
don't have the risk of safety and this
is not your problem I'm saying this to
the people in North Carolina across the
country that are implementing these
policies you are destroying good order
and discipline among various levels of
law enforcement they are you are not
um they're destroying it and I think
that their actions have to have some
legal recourse
now
have there been any Communications with
uh to what extent have you or people up
in the organization communicate it
to these jurisdictions at a blanket
Sanctuary City policy is not helpful to
Homeland Security
um Senator this is something that I've
spoken with Immigration and Customs
Enforcement ice and CBB extensively
um I do not agree containers have been
issues
I'd have to take a look at that senator
for the record
the number of ice detainers and what I'm
particularly interested in is
granularity the number of ice detainers
the basis for the detainer request and
the disposition of that request by local
entities uh can I get a commitment to
get that information yes Senator and I
um I I want you to know that I share
your concern when a local jurisdiction
has an individual or has information
that would benefit the public safety of
the community and does not share that
information with Immigration and Customs
yeah and we should be clear that I'm not
talking about somebody who got into a
fender bender I'm talking about people
that may be in there for sexual assault
we know they're in there for that for
trafficking or any number of other
potent violent or potentially violent uh
crimes I need that information because I
want to put pressure on
local governments in the state of North
Carolina saying if you want to do this I
want you to be held accountable and to
be held accountable we need to pass the
justice for victims of sanctuary cities
act now I want to talk about the
transnational criminal organization I
didn't know this till today I looked it
up did you know that
Jalisco the cartel
translates into stoned
uh literally it's a it's a informal
adjective so that translates into the
new stone generation one of the two
cartels that cover the uh the breadth of
the northern border they're making 800
million dollars a year I've seen their
agents across the Rio Grande when I'm
there at midnight one o'clock saying
we're coming
um we are aiding and abetting one of the
most profitable lines of business these
thieves and these murderers have going
we have a crisis at the border and like
Senator Welch I'm not someone who's just
saying secure the Border I'm also saying
someone please fix the broken Asylum
system and the immigration system even
touching on what Senator ossoff has
discussed but until we have consensus
that we have a crisis we have to work on
a bipartisan basis for those who say
secure the Border not willing to talk
about immigration they're going to allow
another six to ten million people come
in before we fix it over the next five
or eight years for those who say we
don't have an immigration problem
there's just too many facts to uh to
argue against it so Mr Marcus if I could
especially get the information that I
want on the ice detainers and then we're
going to continue to work on the crisis
at the border and and hopefully make
some progress it's unsafe for the
American people it is causing the deaths
of Untold numbers of people making the
dangerous journey and I could go a long
way and I won't because I've already got
the gavel tap on Asylum reform and I
believe if we want to look at Asylum
reform differently we need to look at
our treaty obligations and we need to
say it needs to go further Upstream than
just what we do and when I see fact
patterns where people are moving through
two or three or four
Nations that they could apply for Asylum
before they get to the United States
that looks a lot to me like an
exploitation of our Asylum policy thank
you Mr chair thank you very much Senator
Tillis and thank you Mr secretary you've
given us four hours and I know that uh
some of the questioning has been tough
and challenging I do believe the
majority of senators on both sides of
the table have been professional and
respectful and a very controversial and
tough subject I apologize for those who
were not I can't control them with this
I'll do my best we're going to have
questions for the record they'll be
submitted by 5 PM on Tuesday April 4th
we hope you can answer on a timely basis
without the hearing stands adjourned
thank you Mr chairman
thank you
foreign
[Laughter]